e
good
morning we are a bit late because of
technical
difficulties uh the chairman is running
late and asked me to start this at 10:
and due to technical difficulties uh it
is virtually
10 so uh HP
297 uh non gerain Amendment and I'd like
to hear
from uh Insurance yes my friend
commissioner DJ to explain it until John
Hunt gets here so you know all the good
stuff uh so let's hear what's going on
with this non gerain Amendment
wow that is I get the holy
Trio thank that's a very dangerous
assignment you've given me Mr chairman
because it sounds like you want me to
talk as long as I need to to stall for
representative hunt and I can certainly
talk he's he he and I talked already on
the phone twice this morning and he said
this this amendment is very important
and if anybody has any questions you
three are the ones to answer them we
will certainly do our best I'll tell you
that Mr chairman so if I might DJ beton
cour as you know commissioner of the New
Hampshire insurance department I'm
joined here at the table by Christian
citarella who is our PNC actuary and
Emily dhy who is our PNC legal
counsel I want to go a step further
Beyond just introducing the two
individuals here to either side of me
they have done incredible hard work in
designing the program that we're going
to talk about this morning they have
done a lot of research they've thought
through a lot of things we've gone
through thousands of drafts uh they've
done really good work here I'm
incredibly grateful for the effort that
they've put into this project a project
that I strongly believe in and I
strongly believe in it because I think
it is going to be able to help the
people of this state be able to afford
their home insurance
premiums so very quickly why are you
seeing this before you as a non-gain
Amendment so when we made the decision
as a department to bring this um
proposal forward because there is a
budgetary impact it made sense to me to
include it as part of the Department's
proposed budget as an item within House
Bill 2 we actually had to make that
decision back in the late summer early
fall the elections took place
legislative leadership was selected and
so we had a meeting with the leadership
in both the House and Senate and I
basically asked them how they wanted us
to approach this particular program I
explained to them why I thought it was
an appropriate House Bill two item but I
said we will engage this process however
you would like and the two pieces of
feedback that I got were we'd like to
see as much detail behind this program
as possible in the statute so don't go
looking for some
you know broad Authority around a
framework in statute via the rules
process rather put as much detail into
the proposal itself and then if there
needs to be rule making later that's
fine but we want to make sure that the
legislature has appropriate and
appropriate understanding of exactly
what this program is and exactly how it
will work so that's why the amendment
before you is a bit meaty and the second
thing the leadership instructed us to do
was to to take this proposal through the
policy committees to have it
appropriately vetted and so here we are
in front of the most important policy
Committee in the
house so in any event I'm pleased to um
I'm pleased to present to you this
morning our proposal for the granted
State home mitigation and resiliency
program the slide deck in front of you
I've really tried to keep this
fundamental and simple and then we can
go into as much detail based on the
questions that you have as you would
like so very very simply what is the
problem as I've discussed with you
before homeowners are facing the burden
of soaring insurance premiums in
increases thereof which has created a
formidable barrier to people not only
being able to maintain their home
insurance coverages but it's also hurt
home ownership as well because as you
know it is a
condition of a bank that you have
homeowners insurance coverage in order
for them to issue you a mortgage so you
have to have it and so the problem again
is the increasing premiums for
homeowners insurance coverage which
again is putting strain on strains on
family budgets individuals budgets is a
barrier to home
ownership it's becoming a real
problem so what are the causes of the
problem well here again we've talked a
little bit about this before industry is
working its way through what is
currently a hard market and so insurance
companies are adopting a more selective
approach to the risks that they are
willing to underwrite and again that
leaves consumers having to navigate an
increasingly challenging environment
where they either have to go to a new
carrier that again is not offering them
the same affordable premiums as they had
before or they're being non-renewed
entirely within the admitted market and
so what they're having to do is go see
coverage in the Surplus lines Market
which is very very costly for them some
of the contributing factors to this as
again we've talked about before are
things like inflation interest rates the
global supply chain disruption
litigation costs um and the large
catastrophic weather events those are
the component pieces of what's driving
the current hard Market this
contributing again to companies being a
little bit more restrictive in their
underwriting and so therefore causing
there to be not as much access to
Affordable coverage as existed
before so not to blow too too quickly
through the presentation here but I
think I've described the problem I've
described the causes of the problem and
so here's where this program comes into
play put very very simply what we would
like to do is to create what essentially
will be a dedicated
fund this is a proactive program I want
to be very clear about that this is not
a postd disaster type program this is
not anything that femo would do or hsem
here at the state level this is a
proactive program by which we would
create a fund and the fund would be the
dollars that would go into that fund
would be the first million dollar that
the department collects through the
insurance premium
tax would go into this fund and then
consumers would be able to apply into
the fund on a first come first sered
basis for Grants upwards of
$110,000 to be able to undertake some
improvement of their home and
property the good news is we are not
blazing a trail here this is a program
that has been undertaken I Believe by at
this point seven or eight states either
have these programs currently in place
or are in the process of standing them
up so we know the program works we have
some data as to the benefit the program
has had in those states that being said
I think the state that's had it the
longest is Alabama and Alabama's had it
operational for only about 2 years years
so we have some data but not a ton of it
not because it doesn't exist but because
again the program has not been in
existence long enough for us to be able
to have a comprehensive set of data for
you but I think by virtue of the fact
that you see a lot of members of
Industry here both those who represent
insurance carriers more broadly and some
of the carriers are represented
individually here who are here in
support of this program it is a
testament to the fact that the program
achieves the objectives and the
outcomes that it is set out to achieve
which is to provide relief to homeowners
for their homeowners insurance premiums
so of the data that we have in Alabama
over 60,000 homes have been fortified
they've issued 8,000 grants in Louisiana
North Carolina they've seen lower
premiums and insurance discounts for
proactive homeowners and again there's
opportunities for savings both in terms
of better positioning yourself in the
underwriting to get a lower premium but
then there are also companies that offer
a wider range of discounts up front if
you are able to make certain
improvements again to your home or
property so some of the more prominent
projects that would be eligible for
funding via this grant would be things
like fortifying your roof for ifying the
exterior of your home if there is
foundational work that can be done to
better protect the home from
floods that would be eligible and one of
the things that I think is going to have
the most benefit to the most number of
people is it makes eligible to things
that could be done on the property
itself to make the home safer and the
most prominent example of that is that
large tree
that is hanging over the house or has
very large limbs that are hanging over
the house and because of the size of the
tree and the height of the tree it is
expensive to get rid of it and so
therefore becomes cost prohibitive to a
lot of people so in this instance the
individual would be able to apply into
the fund would be able to get that tree
taken down for
$3,351 and I cite that because that was
what my folks had to pay to have a big
old tree taken down in the front of
their
property and for that
fairly um that that fairly inexpensive
investment there they're going to be way
better positioned in underwriting and
they're going to be able to save on
their
premiums so we're excited about that
because again the million dollars is the
million dollars and we're we designed
this program in a way where we're trying
to have have those dollars assist the
greatest number of people and so not
every Grant is going to be for the full
10,000 there will be a lot of other
smaller projects that'll be well below
that threshold that will be able to go
out and again while it's small
dollars for them it's a huge impact in
terms of their long-term affordability
for coverage so we're excited about
those um aspects of the
program so at this point I'll just pause
Emily or Christian is there anything at
this point critical that I've missed
before I get into some of the other
highlights I think
you my team says I've done well so far I
guess I'm on a roll
um so in any event we're trying to start
modestly uh it is a million dollars
which is not obviously nothing um but
again we're going to find ways to make
those dollars count we have also heard
over the course of the last year to year
and a half a number of rumors uh coming
from Washington granted there are always
rumors coming from Washington but we are
hearing that there is some interest in
Congress to make some uh block granting
available to States for these programs
either to start them or to be able to
put more resources into currently
existing programs so we will have them a
million dollars of State funding that
will go in every year and you will see
there that we have asked for any unspent
dollars for I think the first three
years or was it five five for the first
five years to roll over simple reason
being that it takes time for word of a
program to get out to the public so
there'll be an educational aspect of
this as well and we're working very
closely with the New Hampshire Home
Builders Association uh to let their
folks know that there will be
opportunities for their contractors to
be able to do more work and that this is
a program we hope they will have
conversations with the individual
consumers that they work with or
interact with to let them know that this
program is available for them to take
advantage of so we're hoping that we'll
have a very aggressive Grassroots
communication strategy so that folks
will know of the existence of this
program but uh we'll have the dollars
that are unspent roll over for the first
five years and thereafter any unspent
dollars will go right back into the
general
fund so we'll be judicious with the
money as well but should the federal
government make additional dollars
available because the program exists
we'll have a vehicle we'll be able to
drop those dollars right into and at
that point we'll come back and probably
have a conversation with you about
adjusting some of the eligibility
criteria to be able to again impact uh
even more positively impact even more uh
Granite Staters but we're going to start
modestly because the dollars are modest
and then we'll build out from there as
the situation should
dictate go ahead oh I would also mention
too again the idea being to have the
dollars that we have in this program
impact the people who are most in need
of it uh there is a means test testing
component to the program our means
testing criteria is identical to the uh
home heating assistance program weather
the weatherization program that the New
Hampshire Department of energy overseas
and administers we thought that um
adopting a model that worked well that
we knew worked well for one other state
agency in a somewhat similar uh related
subject matter would be beneficial
certainly we hope it's something that
you're comfortable and familiar with so
we didn't reinvent the wheel uh we went
with something that had been tried true
and tested uh so again there's means
testing there we want to make sure that
we're targeting the people who really
are the most in need and who would most
benefit from having some support via
this
program so that all being said from my
perspective Ive again I think there are
a number of wins and benefits to the
program first obviously lowering
people's homeowners insurance
premiums at worst keeping them out of
the Surplus lines
Market but also not to be lost is the
fact that people are going to be living
in safer homes and that is a benefit in
in of itself and so people's homes their
properties will be safer for them safer
for their families safer for any members
of the public who may have reason to
come on to that property so that's good
as well inl look while I appreciate the
fact that um the home builders are
busier than ever these days uh this will
also be an opportunity in the periods
when they're a bit down or when the in
that industry is not going quite as Gang
Busters it'll be a good opportunity for
them to have steady consistent
work uh to engage in and again help the
consumers of the
state so representative Hunt is here
I've done my job I F A Buster just long
enough for you to get here Mr chairman
um there's a lot to this program
obviously and I know that this will go
to work session when it goes to work
session we are going to invite in a
gentleman by the name of Brian Powell
Brian Powell used to be the deputy
insurance commissioner of the state of
Alabama he is actually the
brain behind this program Alabama was
the first state to stand it
up uh I've engaged therefore in my
favorite uh uh kind of work which is R&D
ripoff and duplicate uh We've improved
it I think we have taken a different
approach uh than some of the other
programs have again to try to address
not just helping a home become certified
under the
ibhs standard but again for those who
are not quite as ambitious to go in that
direction to be able to take on smaller
projects that are still going to be very
beneficial uh to them a Brian was
poached from Alabama to work for the
National Association of insurance
Commissioners the
niic and his job all day every day that
he is there is to assist States in
designing and bringing these programs
online he has been a tremendous asset to
us as we were designing our program
um I think we challenged some of his um
uh previously held beliefs about how
some of this can work I think we've
broadened his Horizons and a the result
of that is we've been approached by
three other states who have said we
understand that you're looking at this
in a pretty interesting way in an
Innovative way would like to understand
what you're doing which is great and I
think two of those states are our
Northern New England neighbors because
we've really tried to New Hampshire eyes
this program obviously the types of
weather weather threats weather
potential uh is a lot different in New
Hampshire than it is in Alabama or
Louisiana or Florida all of which have
either exactly this program or something
similar to it uh so our Northern New
England Partners want to know what we've
done because obviously we share a lot of
the same weather uh characteristics so I
really think we're on to something very
very viable something very Innovative
but we'll make Brian available to you
during the work session he can really
dive into the detail of any questions
that you have and again he'll have the
benefit of being able to tell you all of
the experiences and the background and
the stories
behind why we've done certain things in
in a lot of ways we've done them either
because they've worked well in other
states and Brian would be able to speak
to that or because it didn't work so
well uh in some other states and there
again Brian will be able to uh bring you
through the detail of all of that but
for today certainly happy to answer as
many of your questions as we can uh
represent
shes so um thank you Mr chairman thanks
for a question so as the bill 297 FN
what is I mean the first part of the
bill relates to the employer health
benefits which is health insurance
company and then second part of the bill
you're talking about home
insurance uh what's the I I would say
just out of the block I'm sorry I have a
I have a history no my question is why
comb that history where it says purpose
and policy that's gone Mr chairman I
think what he's speaking to I think he's
a little bit tripped up he came in a
little bit late when I explained why
this is a non-gain Amendment oh so it's
a non-gain Amendment because when we
originally were approaching this program
we had it as a part of our house bill
two requests and then we got feedback
back from leadership in the House and
Senate that they wanted it to go through
the committee process so that the
subject matter experts all of you had
the opportunity to vet it so what we
needed to do was to find some Bill that
we could attach this to so that we could
have this non- gerain bill hearing and
there would actually be a vehicle for it
to move forward to house finance I
assume if all of you are in support of
this program so yes the title of the
bill and the amendment are two totally
separate subject matter uh subject
matters but this is the way we had to do
it in order to make it all work for the
process you have we got the feedback
from leadership about how they wanted us
to approach this after the bill you okay
with that do you understand okay so
basically we have a process here in
which um in terms of when we amend bills
in Committee in the subcommittee and we
amend bills the bill the amendments are
directly related to that issue of that
bill now over the years um and and let's
say the Senators taken more advantage of
this than we in the house do which is
that they'll take any Bill and they'll
take any other issue that had nothing to
do with it and slap it on that bill okay
so we have a policy here in the house
that says that if you're going to do
that if you're going to take a n a
nerain no words it's not anything to do
with the title of the bill or the
original purpose of the bill or whether
the original sponsor even knows that
were doing it through their
bill okay that we're taking an amendment
we're adding to it but we're having a
proper public hearing so no one can ever
said this thing came out of nowhere I
don't know anything about this or have
we had a fair opportunity to discuss
and thoroughly thrash out what the
purpose of the bill is and whether it's
appropriate for public
policy okay I mean maybe we can talk
more detail during the subcommittee uh
uh that time but I'm I'm still having
hard time understanding that I
understand the technicality of this what
you why you're doing is okay but the
point is that because these two are two
different subject matters yes and uh
somebody could be opposed to the first
part while somebody could be okay with
the second part how are they going to
vote on the B so what we do when we get
into the subcommittee yeah we can talk
we we we will thrash out both pieces
okay okay and and and uh the underlying
Bill uh I'm not sure remember what the
about so so so the sponsor does know
about the
bill know about this non Amendment okay
okay and this uh and the simple little I
would say that one of the reasons why we
chose this bill is because both the both
both these issues are something that the
department is requesting okay so the
underlying bill that it was a simple
little Bill that it's an ongoing issue
that we have um that you know that that
we will we will discuss both pieces and
so theoretically in subcommittee or in
the full committee we might decide to
accept one or the other or neither you
know so we'll we'll have that choice but
so I would say is um if you were to look
at the title of the bill now what you
want to do is say the the bill now has
two analysis has two different issues in
it yes and and because we've had this
non gerain hearing okay that's fine I
think I'm good for now but we can talk
later on on this fair enough
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr share um is anyone is
the insurance department or anyone going
to testify um on the original
Bill yes representative I I believe that
bill has been heard we we already had
that here
in thank you I forgot
okay
okay silly thank thank you for taking my
question can you you may you may have
mentioned it but can you please repeat
who is going to administer the program
is it part of your depart if it's part
of your department will you need
additional headcount I didn't see that
so the department will administer the
program for us we're going to dedicate
one individual to do it I have the
position already I'm going to repurpose
a currently existing position uh for
administering this program and what we
foresee and we'll obviously need to work
with treasury in terms of getting the
dollars out the door that's not my
understanding is anything unusual M us
are signed quite frequently between
agencies and treasury to make sure that
everything flows and works exactly as it
should but really for this individual
within the department it will be taking
the grant applications ensuring that
the application is in alignment with
eligibility the eligibility criterias in
the program and then again as I've said
it's a first come first serve basis so
this individual will start with the
applications at the top go through get
to the Million dooll number and then we
will probably uh put forward a system
that will hang on to the applications
that we've received that were not
approved because the funds had been
expended already and we'll check in with
the homeowner as the opportunity for
them to reapply becomes available the
next year to see if they want their
Grant to remain under consideration or
whether or not it's not needed anymore
because they either decided to do the
work themselves
or you know the tree that they wanted to
get rid of went down on its own
hopefully not into their house but uh
it's a first come first serve basis the
one individual who admin it will just be
taking in the applications making sure
they're eligible and then communicating
with treasury to get the dollars out the
door okay so but to answer your question
it's a very important question who's
going to administrate and who's going to
do this okay yes they're going to find
an in-house position this bill if we
decide to go forward with it with this
amendment is going to go to finance and
finance might say no we don't want that
position at
all and and this bill will die you know
then you know die and and they might get
rid of that position but that will be up
to finance in terms of figuring out how
makes more sense to operate the
department but then they would have to
follow up to make sure the work was
completed as contracted well I would at
this point if they weren't willing to
fund the position no if they do if they
fund the position the position and this
person goes out to say oh look the tree
came down the tree has been removed
appropriately yes there will be a the
idea is you're doing it ahead of time
this is I keep turn to saying because I
did get a a phone call from a former
legislator this is um proactive rather
than
reactive so in terms of proactive is is
that the the pro the program is in place
that it's in there so it's up to the
individual
homeowner to say I want to take
advantage of they proactively they need
to apply and then uh in terms of then
making the making sure all the Hoops
have been jumped through and everything
uh the money comes from the fact that we
already have a tax you know for the the
uh insurance tax so it's not uh but that
I mean reality is I don't think this is
going to get used a lot uh a is people
might be in denial whether it exists and
how well they Market it and let
everybody know it exists but B is most
people love that big old tree and just
think it's the most beautiful thing in
the world and it pains them to think
that maybe they should cut it
down but at this case if they they
didn't cut it down and it falls on top
of their house they can't blame they
only have themselves to blame for not
taking care of that I just wanted to
make sure I understood the process so
they apply for the grant which it
doesn't have to be paid back and they
say I'm going to take down the old tree
right they get the money but then they
never take down the tree oh
yeah program for that Emily's going to
speak to that piece if I might so we
have a position in the department
currently that is currently funded we
would just repurpose that position for
administration of this program so
there's no new money in terms of
personnel what I also mention to my
friends over at house finances I've
already defunded three positions
full-time and two part-time positions so
I've really tried to do my part on the
position front now despite the fact that
I don't know how much good it does them
since we're a self-funded agency but I
got into this Spirit of what they were
looking for so hopefully they'll let me
keep this currently funded position and
again so how do we make sure no one
we're not going to get scammed and if I
could I'll just direct everybody to page
four line 17 that's going to be there in
out um um as the commissioner noted um
the proposed 407 E9 is the provision
that speaks about the payment of the
funds and so under that provision the um
applicant would have to show that um all
the work had been completed and it
requires um certain things including a
copy of the signed contract a copy of
the itemized work and a sworn affidavit
from the contractor who performed the
work um so we are um the bill proposes
including safeguards to make sure the
work was actually
completed and again that's a model that
we borrowed from the other programs and
so far as we can tell in terms of the
feedback that we've gotten that
provision has worked very well to ensure
that the work is done and that nobody's
making off with the dollars there's also
some Provisions in here that say that
the payment will be made post the work
being done but we understand that in
some cases the contractor is going to
need some upfront payment in order to be
able to procure the materials that are
needed to do that work so there'll be
those doll will be made available
upfront so the work can begin then the
rest of the payment will follow once the
project is done so those um safeguards
are present and as I've said based on
the experience of the other states they
have worked
well okay yes representative
Herbert
um is there any uh anything in this uh
project that might be able to
generate
cash um outside of the
insurance uh coverage in other words if
somebody
has $6,000 project and you say fine and
you do the project can the person that
had the project say uh would it be okay
if I spent some of my own
money uh and you know a million bucks is
going to go fast M so I'm just trying to
think of any AD avenues that might be
available to generate uh cash sure I
think if I've understood your question
correctly so the the dollars from the
grant program can be used but it's not
like that's as far as the project can go
so for example if you need a brand new
roof depending on the size of the home
but let's say it's a single family ranch
style uh roof um that's probably going
to run you somewhere in the neighborhood
of about
$20,000 right so you're going to have
the 10 from the grant that you'll be
able to bring to bear but obviously the
homeowner is going to have to account
for the other 10 in order for that whole
project to be complete um as you'll see
here there's kind of two tracks that the
consumer can choose to go on there's the
track to be uh
ibhs certified gold star standard and
again depending on the house that's
probably a longer term project there are
a lot of aspects that go into meeting
all of those standards you're not going
to be able to get there just on a
$10,000 Grant from this program but
obviously the grant can be helpful and
if you do have the resources as as an
individual homeowner that you can bring
to beay you may be able to fully tackle
all of the components that go into that
ibhs
certification but for those who don't
want to go down that comprehensive route
again have created a second track where
people can take on smaller more modest
projects that again while small
seemingly to them is going to end up
paying them significant dividends when
it comes to underwriting getting renewed
getting quoted for a premium not getting
tossed into the Surplus lines Market uh
so I I I hope that was your question
like I like that answer the big the
savings is going to come when they get a
cheaper right homeowners policy because
they've addressed that problem right
right representa Ammon thank you Mr
chair and thank you for coming and
testifying I just want to understand the
position sort of piggybacking on what
representative teresia had asked um
House Bill 297 the original bill is not
part of the amendment right the
amendment says amend the bill page one
line six amend the bill by replacing all
after section one with the
following the the following is the the
gr State home mitigation and resiliency
program the original Bill appears
nowhere in the text of this as far as I
can I can see so the original bill is is
uh gone yeah we may have to make an
adjustment there I think we drafted this
amendment as though it were an
assignment we typically get from you
which is to say we need you to rewrite
this bill so I I think that's why that
language was there but no we certainly
do want to keep the underlying policy
matter um originally included in House
Bill uh 297 and then have this as part
of that as
well okay okay after section all
so the former commissioner is still
taking good care of me over
here so the original text of House Bill
297 is all contained in that section one
representative so the amendment as it's
written would just tack this on but
preserve what's currently there in 297 I
see so the the Roman numeral 5 on the
original bills is still going to well
this is a good time for everybody to
learn a little bit of how crazy our
legislative process can be if you look
at the bill you'll see it says on line
six amend the bill by replacing all
after section
one so if you go back and look at the
original bills section one the original
language of the bill and then it says uh
um then and then now section two so it
it is a little uh when it says replacing
with the following so that that means
they try to fix the title amand The Bill
replacing all after section one the key
element there is that these little
numbers on the on the left hand side and
you would say we'll see some other bills
like Department bills where that'll be
up to 10 or 11 cuz are all these
different sections of the bill that that
they're taking in but uh the key element
is each section is going to flow with
one RSA it's going to be one thought in
terms of as an RSA is listed so just a
followup yeah so all after section one
on the original bill it's it's really
only talking about line 24 of the
original bills the effective date that's
replaced correct so that's really what
it's replacing it will be the effective
date which I think was a problem with
the orig bill in the first I think there
was going to need to be an adjustment
there anyhow yeah it's a little wonky I
mean not to complicate matters I suspect
what'll end up happening is if we are
able to get you all comfortable with
this program you move it along it's
going to go to house finance and house
finance will probably cleave off this
program from 297 and consider it within
the larger context of House Bill 2 and
everything else that they're working
through right now is good so this is
another thing we need to bring up for
your freshman okay uh when it comes to
the budget we actually have two bills we
have uh House Bill one and House Bill
two House Bill two is also is known as
the trailer bill because it implements
everything that's in house bill one
otherwise it's known as the Christmas
tree and where everything all the
different issues are all dangling off
this wonderful tree
so representative buros has a question
thank you so much
I have a question I have a constituent
who lives in a flood zone she has a
house and actually she is the mother of
somebody in this committee and um that I
don't care what you do to that house
that house is going to fall into the
river one day so would people in those
situ situations where climate or
flooding is going to be inevitable would
this program um be U available to them
because of the particular
characteristics of where the house is
located it's probably going to be tough
for them to ever be able to position
themselves to do well in underwriting
it's probably incredibly difficult for
them to get flood insurance I assume
they have to go through the national
flood insurance program and if they
don't have a policy through them I don't
know who this person is beg them to do
it uh whatever you do don't let them
have the assumption that they've got
flood insurance coverage via their
underlying homeowners coverage way too
many people make that assumption and
then disaster strikes and they are some
of the most Miser able conversations I
have to have with constituents because
they've just lost everything they
thought they have coverage and they are
completely out of luck what was the
agency so it's the national flood
insurance program it is a federal
program obviously backstopped by the
federal government that makes flood
coverage available to individuals who
cannot get coverage in the commercial
Market because of where they happen to
be located which if they're in a flood
plane and you're fear is that eventually
that home's going to fall into the river
they're going to have to go through
nfip so Mr musk hasn't eliminated that
agency yet not that I'm aware of not
that I'm aware of would you
believe
okay thank you very much all right very
good I got one card
here from the
former
commissioner yeah and DJ uh can you make
sure there's a card you guys made a card
thanks chairman hunt members of the
committee I'm going to teach hold on a
second
yes yes represent Spirit the um the
million dollars that's going to go to
paying for the program I thought it was
like a 100,000 or 200,000 was a million
okay so it's going to come out of the
premiums premium tax the premium tax
ordinarily that money would go into the
eneral fund
correct okay so the finance committee
could very easily that's why this is
this exactly okay so this all might be
for not but we're we're giving her
College try yes good morning Chris
chairman hunt members of the committee
my name is Chris nicopoulos uh I'm here
representing the National Association of
mutual insurance companies which is one
of the largest trade associations for
PNC insurance carriers some 60% of uh
Insurance written in New Hampshire is
written by by one of our members uh and
we're here to support uh the
commissioner's Amendment on this bill uh
we've seen a number of states adopt
resiliency or fortified home bills that
have been very effective uh there are a
number of states looking at including
Maine is looking at funding a program
with nearly $15 million in the ld1 the
governor's
budget uh this plan though it's not a
tremendous amount of money will allow
New Hampshire to test what was
successful in Alabama ultimately Alabama
put a program in like this has had an
opportunity to have cat losses and it's
looked at the houses that were fortified
as compared to the houses that weren't
and there was a drastic reduction in
claim level for those houses uh and so
the industry is supportive of the
commissioner's efforts I'm happy to
questions represent a thank you for your
testimony um if this is such a good idea
why doesn't the insurance industry fund
these these programs
good question representative uh because
this is it's good for everyone right
it's good for all of our uh citizens to
have U Better Built Homes uh an
insurance company in any given case
can't afford to uh uh fortify a home you
know think of what your uh home owners
premiums are as opposed to a 10,000
Grant I there's not sufficient money
there uh to do that I think ultimately
taking a money from the premium tax is a
roundabout way to to test this program
but ultimately I think the good of
citizens in total benefits from that it
fund thank you very much thank you all
right having no more cards I will close
the uh public hearing on the non- gerain
okay okay
so uh While most of the committee
members are here um just next week we
will be doing subcommittees on all these
early bills so this but we will be
taking this bill up next
week and because it's just a
subcommittee um we can have we can we
don't necessarily need to have a big the
big committee room so um I might I I
have the availability of room
104 which is down on the first floor so
that uh that we'll do use that on
Tuesday and I'll just decide which ones
I put in put in there
so Tuesday and
week don't go far right
okay you want to give me your cell phone
person
okay we'll open up to public hearing and
hear from the prime
sponsor reg uh representative stringing
I I guess before we get too far into
this um I want to make sure everyone
everyone in the room knows that we've
already had a hearing on the issue so
let's put it this way I would I'm fully
confident that the committee
members understand the problem so what I
would have you do is focus your
discussion on why you think this bill is
the right answer rather than the other
ones so you feel free to contrast but
again and is is uh let's you don't have
to explain to us the problem we for some
of us who have been doing this for a
very long time I know the problem very
intimately but for new members I think
pretty well everybody's pretty well up
to speed good morning uh good morning
thank you Mr chairman and esteemed
members of the Commerce uh committee and
uh consumer affairs uh I'm pleased to
introduce House Bill
725 uh relative to ground ambulances
services
my name is Jerry Stringham I'm a
representative from Lincoln Woodstock uh
Easton and Livermore um my personal
background includes over 25 years as a
consultant in healthcare reimbursement
systems uh particularly related to
various fee schedules relating to things
like Physician Services Hospital
outpatient services and so on uh so that
gives me some uh some uh relevant
experience uh for this different Fe
schedu Bas mainly the ambulance services
uh this bill uh does two things extends
the prohibition on balance billing uh to
ground ambulances services and
establishes a non-contract rate for
ambulance services for those insured
with commercial uh health plans at 20 at
325 per of the Medicare rate for those
plans that that have not negotiated a
rate uh with that particular ambulance
provider uh obviously this isn't an
ideal situation uh this is a service uh
that uh New Hampshire rights have been
used to getting uh without uh having
additional uh these additional monies
being needed and whether the money uh
comes from insurance companies whether
public or private uh from the patients
themselves or from property taxpayers
we're talking about new money here uh
and this is this situation has been
created uh and I know we've talked about
it a little bit uh as the ground
ambulance uh business model has broken
down and has been discussed in this
committee and uh part of the
presentation on two other bills one of
which I testified on uh so the old
business model has collapsed uh and
services uh providing ambulance care
have shut down in working on last uh
bance budget for four ambulance
providers had gone belly up in three
months during the time we were working
on the budget and obviously uh that
caught everyone's attention including
this
committee uh at the same time the
crippling impacts of a single ambulance
ambulance bill can still financially uh
ruin an individual uh and E efforts to
extend the prohibition of balance
billing uh because of the problems with
the business model and ground ambulances
have not yet extended to that so uh I
think we saw uh the commissioner's Bill
uh uh while using a different model to
to uh make up the Lost uh funds that are
needed uh uh still also uh included a
balance uh billing prohibition as this
bill does as
well uh uh the ambulance um this bill
provides ambulance service providers
with sufficient Insurance reimbursements
to stabilize their business and protect
our ambulance riding consumers from
Financial ruin at the same time and
that's basically the two purposes we're
we're trying we're uh approaching here
uh the Bill's uh sponsors have been part
of the commissioner's ambulance study
which led to the publication of the New
Hampshire ground ambulance cost study on
December 23rd uh which is additional
information that's available and I would
like to uh uh congratulate both the
authors and the insurance commissioner
uh for the uh work that's been done
there uh it's an important study that
underscores some of the challenges faced
by the business model for ambulance
services for example uh in establishing
the cost of the services it assumes that
uh the ambulance providers will continue
to receive funds from towns and donors
at the same level so uh that means uh uh
there's still money outside of those
paid by the people who are actually
getting the ride and I know I have five
t-shirts at home that's a a lywood
ambulance running 5K on them and uh uh
uh so you know the these are uh often
Charities that uh do receive money
outside of um uh the payments they
receive and uh this cost study assumed
those would continue to be on there uh
and uh um you know that was part of the
questions that came up on that um the
the idea of balancing uh uh the the idea
of continuing to have the balance
billing in place uh in part was meant to
uh create um sufficient incentives for
insurance companies and providers to
still have a re reason to negotiate so
if somebody gets a bill uh for thousands
of dollars for an ambulance ride that
they weren't even awake for and didn't
even ask for uh they go go back to the
insurance company and soon sooner or
later there could be some some
resolution in there the idea of having
the
325 which according to my records here
in some cases will be more than than
than the invoice so the actual payment
would still be below that amount um uh
would provide sufficient Capital that uh
we can we can get rid of that that
incentive in there um and uh you know
using the cost study the anticipated
cost to an insurer uh in in in the
insurance model the insurance model is
about 36 cents per member per month that
is how insurance companies generally
think about is a program expensive or
not uh this model would probably be
closer to 60 per member per month or
about $7.20 a year uh in premium uh
although uh you know I think that's open
to some some discussion um again this uh
again this would only apply to
non-contract providers there's nothing
that would prevent an Anthem Sigma or
any of those insurance companies from
negotiating uh a rate uh with with the
providers directly uh you know this
model uh uh provides no cost to the
state taxpayers I think the my my
reading of of uh the commissioner's
model which uh asks that all insurers
pay the same amount uh would mean that
the Medicaid rates would go up so there
would be some impact uh to state
taxpayers which I'm not sure uh there's
a stomach four right now uh and my
experience in working with Medicare uh
in fee schedules and waivers is that uh
is would be very difficult to get
additional money from Medicare
specifically targeted in New Hampshire
when they do waivers it's
typically uh the state comes up and says
you're providing this much money for
ground ambulance
services uh but you want us to pay this
much for transport and this much for uh
emergency care we would rather just lump
Summit we want to do it we want to
spread the money around differently we
don't want to use your fee schedule and
they often ask for waivers so when we
talked at the last meeting about the
Maryland program Mar Maryland is has a
waiver and doesn't use the drg system
for paying hospitals uh for that
specifically that reason in 1983 when
the system came out they said we don't
like that system and we wanted to use
our own and said if you can meet your
cost production targets you can continue
to do that and amazingly to all of us 42
years later they're still doing it so um
uh if if my understanding is of the
commissioner's bill and I guess we'll
all come back uh uh in subcommittee and
and review the three bills that were put
together um uh you know I I do think
that's kind of a a flaw or that would
have to be addressed um
I I do think unfortunately it is normal
for commercial rates to be higher than
Medicare and Medicaid and um uh so um I
uh onepay uh systems are quite quite
unusual uh so as I said I understand the
three bills addressing the topic will be
discussed uh and I um I'm sure any of
them could be uh a move to get something
that'll work from the ambulance
providers
and for our citizens that unfortunately
need a ride from time to time uh with
that I will open up to any questions
that you may have I know we have a lot
of other experts here to speak as
well representa
SES so um so thanks for a question I
have actually two- part question first
is based on experience current in the
current system the way you are doing
balance billing what percentage of
balance billing you are able to recover
that's first question and second
question is that how are you going to
address the ambulance services to people
insurance um so let's see one question
is how how how do ambulance service
providers handle their customers that
don't have insurance there a second
question the first was in the current
balance building system that you have MH
what percentage you able to recover from
the balance billing do you have
information on that uh there is there
there are some recoveries that get that
way but in in Lincoln Woodstock I know
the numbers are not significant I mean I
mean so you don't have any ballpark like
50% 25% there there'll be other people
testifying and we'll have one of them
give you a hard a harder percentage Yeah
and in terms of under uninsured get
bills and whether they pay them or not
is uh uh
um uh is
often a matter of litigation so
so representative Amon thank you Mr
chair thank you for your testimony um
you're welcome just because I don't know
what the term means I'm I'm asking so I
three it said I I'll read the whole
sentence if a claim that a health
carrier receives for ambulance service
provided to a covered individual by a
non-participating ambulance service
provider is not a clean claim what what
does a clean claim
mean uh well in the way I would use
clean claim is sometimes a claim comes
and it has all the information like what
the diagnosis is uh the information that
the insurance company would normally
need to see to make sure that this
patient is eligible uh for insurance and
that it's a diagnosis that's appropriate
for the type of service that's been
given I'll give an examp example of a um
you know we're putting in the non the
non-transport as a uh reimbursable event
but uh the if if an ambulance service
goes to uh say a car crash and uh the
person just waves them off and said I
don't want to see anything uh there's
been no medical intervention provided
that's actually still would not be
billable but if they put hook an IV in
they give somebody Nar can uh then they
say they don't want then that would be
billable so there would need to be a
claim with adequate uh documentation so
that the insurance company should
process the claim and to me that's what
a clean claim is and if if they have to
send it back for clarification then it's
an unclean
claim okay any other questions see none
thank you very
much uh chair will'll call on Michael
satar from the New Hampshire Association
of Fire Chiefs he didn't say he was for
or against the bill but I'm going to
going to guess that I had it in the
right
four if you don't mind I have Chief Ed
Walker with me he's uh there are two of
us in that does he have a card in with
oh good great I like
that
perfect all right good morning my name
is Mike Zar I'm the chief of the Tilton
norfield fire district and I'm
representing the New Hampshire
Association of Fire Chiefs my
counterpart is Ed Walker he's the Chief
Peter Barrow and representing the fire
chiefs as well today we're here to speak
in favor of
725 and the reason the the bottom line
is what we want to do is help reduce the
impact to our taxpayers in our community
and every penny that we can get from the
insurance companies going towards the
cost of the services that we're
providing is going to reduce the tax
impact to our taxpayers that's the
bottom
line and to uh to further speak to that
the the two strong points with this bill
are the 325 per and we're handing out um
the full testimony you see in the bottom
the 325 per Alliance close to what a
number of other states in the country
have chosen to be a percentage relative
to the Medicaid rate um which is a
fairly established rate some of those
even here in New England and the other
part of this is the by establishing this
state rate it also helps with in
educating with other insurers or with
other parties about what a fair and
reasonable rate is um for reimbursment
to help recover some of those costs
have okay any questions
anybody like I said they're very well
informed on this issue thank you thank
you okay chair we're calling
Derek uh Ameron
Amon Ammon
Ammon alen book I I know you dick but
Derek but I I don't your name you don't
thank
you here you go thank you uh again thank
you Mr chair committee my name is Derrik
Alman from hookit I am the President of
the New Hampshire Ambulance Association
um we do stand in support of this bill
however um my esteemed colleague uh
Chris staz will testify to our um
components of uh our support I did see
and uh representative Aon I appreciate
your question on what a clean claim is I
do have some uh you know written
documentation in front of you that we
would ask that you consider you know
when we discuss what a clean claim is
because that term has been weaponized by
the insurance agencies and we really
feel that that is something that when
you move forward you know with any
consideration using that term um and I
can go through this line by line you
certainly have it in front of you if
chairman we're going to discuss this in
subcommittee so just give me the
highlights or what do you think think
ISL the most Salient important items we
certainly give it what a definition of a
clean claim is you know to what we
expect you know what is reasonable and
what a reasonable standard that would
apply to what a clean claim is um we ask
for you know the process that would
occur when a clean claim is provided and
a timeline that when a clean claim is
provided as to when the um provider
could expect payment and what the
expectation would be in the event that a
clean claim did not happen and then
because of our experience and certainly
my peers in the aom medical industry
could have testify to this the um the
idea of a clean claim being weaponized
you know if they do not perform we're
looking for some Financial impact in the
form of a penalty you know and the
number that I give here is not only the
cost of the claim but a 100% increase on
that you know claim and plus
25% so I think there does need to be
some Financial penalty because otherwise
we do have experience that the insurance
companies will just sit on things delay
it you know and call forth their you
delay okay so I'm going to throw this
question out for you but it's really for
everybody to think
about is there anything else in the fire
department which you can balance bill
with
now did any other is there a fire in
which you can Bill somebody a balance
bill for because you had to bring your
trucks had to you know take care of them
chairman I am not a firefighter I'm been
a paramedic for 35 years and proud to
say um I'm supportive of firefighters
but when you know the rats are running
out of the building and those people are
running in they're better people than I
believe me um so I I do apologize I I
you're the wrong person to ask yes I
apologize okay
but we're good thank you thank you sir
thank you all right don't have any fire
oops
stas who I know he doesn't say what he's
representing today
but I apologize for that New Hampshire
amb
Association I only have one page I was
trying to be brief so I I know we'll be
at a work session um so the New
Hampshire ambulance my name is Chris day
was I'm a board on the board of
directors for the New Hampshire
Ambulance Association the um Association
supports H Bill 725 it would end the
need for balanc billing in New Hampshire
once and for all which I and and we
believe fill the revenue Gap that would
be created by ending it as I've
previously testified we do not believe
other ambulance reimbursement bills
being considered that by this committee
would accomplish that in a way that is
financially responsible to either the
consumer or the provider or
both the this is not about inequity
between Medicare or Medicaid
reimbursement rates those are important
but separate issues it's about
maintaining a neutral Revenue stream for
all ambulance providers if they are no
longer allowed to balance bill in our
ambulance Summit meetings last year with
the insurance commission the state was
unable to determine the amount ground
ambulance providers collected by balance
billing the PCG report expertly details
the actual costs of the services however
for all of its analysis it seemingly
fails to determine or reveal that amount
either and that is the absolute heart of
the matter at hand I believe all agree
that the financial gap that any
prohibition to collects balanc billing
dollars creates needs to be bridged the
fiscal health of every ambulance
provider in New Hampshire depends on it
particularly in rural areas we believe
that 325 of Medicare will bridge that
Gap and not result in a significant
health insurance premium increase or
spend it is a fair compromise that does
not place any undo additional burden on
the community providing the service the
consumer or the ambulance provider and I
look forward to working with you in work
group or subcommittee group to come up
solution oh representative miles thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
is
325 that is in this bill is this what
you need to maintain EMS
services to the very rural areas and
sick population in this state is this
enough we believe that this would be a
neutral amount if we were if the ability
to balance bill was taken away from the
providers which we all want to do MH
that 325 would make up that Gap okay
will it prevent operations from
closing I don't know the answer to that
this as I said this is one piece of a
giant puzzle um and the focus of this
piece is ending balance billing without
financially harming providers or
you represent Teresa so I thank you for
question uh I bring the same question
that I asked previously since you
mentioned that you are going to with
this bill you're going to bridge the gap
between the balance billing and uh and
the amount that the department receives
so would you have any information about
what percent of balance billing are you
able to recover right now is it 50%
25% 100 75% any any information that's a
great question that percentage varies
widely by the type of a provider that is
doing the balance billing um there are a
number probably more than half of the
ambulance services in New Hampshire are
small you know less than 20 person
operations that um are probably not very
well bursted in in the billing process
so their ability to collect is um not as
good as others could be I don't know an
exact number as I said these reports
were not able to determine that so we
don't have an idea uh we know how much
cost to provide the service but we don't
have a true idea of what that Gap is so
it differs from Ambulance Service to
ambulance service or so do you have any
average at a state level that you're
able to recover so much amount I do not
no that's that's the magic number I
think we're all over the years we've
used the numbers 30% don't
30%
30% any other questions see none thank
you thank
you okay let's change Pace uh Sabrina
Dunlap from Anthem in opposition to the
is thank you chairman hunt and members
of the committee I will be brief
appreciating that there will be more
conversation on this um
I I think it's it's tough to say 325 is
a compromise I'm still unclear on where
that actually came from and the way the
bill is written functionally that will
set a rate of 325 per. I know it lists
municipalities um can set their own rate
but I don't know why anyone would set
something lower than 325 so functionally
we're talking about 325 per of Medicare
um and you know I think we appreciate
the Bandon balance billing also
something we want uh again I want to
emphasize that is something that comes
from the provider to the member I think
there's a misunderstanding sometimes
that it's the insurance company that's
sending that bill to the member so
obviously we support that as well I
think I'm confused by the section on
prompt pay and the comment that um clean
claim is weaponized I don't know what
that what that actually means there is a
very clear statute on this already for
20 j8 um there's lengthy provisions on
prompt pay clean claims
is is defined already so I don't
understand how this would help
um and I think again we are talking
about a very small piece of the pie and
Chris just said that and it's true that
um you know Medicare and Medicaid and
people who aren't insured are a big part
of this as well as our municipalities
and chairman hunt you said that at the
insurance department Bill hearing as
well that this is a section of of
healthcare that is just different and it
doesn't involve the municipalities and I
think to put you know this set rate on
just the fully insured Market I don't
think that's fair I don't think that's
neutral um so I think we would be in
favor of further discussion on the
insurance department bill you know I
think that did the deepest dive we've
seen so far on the true costs for
providers um so obviously happy to talk
more happy to take any questions thank
you for the opportunity to
yes representative
miles thank
you you're from antham oh I'm sorry I
did not introduce myself Spina D I am
the senior director of government
relations for Anthem I apologize do you
currently have Hospital uh ambulance
contracts we do yes so can't you set
your own rate for yourself with why why
do why do why are you against this it's
if if you're able to set your own
contract rate
we do negotiate with ambulance providers
to try to bring them in our Network and
we negotiate those rates I think to set
a rate like this for out of network
providers um I don't think this is a
reasonable rate and it also
disincentivizes any ambulance providers
to come into our Network which we are
always trying to do because it helps our
members to have ambulance providers in
our
Network or exit or not have a contract
do number someone say well pass this
legislation then well correct yeah I
think this would drive ambulance
providers out of our Network I think
that would be a consequence of this bill
as
well thank you very much thank you chair
we'll call in Justin
holderness my name is Justin no you got
to turn it on button there we go sorry
uh my name is Justin van etton I serve
as the chair of Stewart's ambulance
where the largest rural provider of EMS
in New Hampshire uh I also serve as the
chair of Municipal resources we consult
with municipalities throughout the
Eastern Seaboard um comparing the two
bills uh two issues that I wanted to
bring up the first is I've been meeting
with cities and towns Boards of
Selectmen City councils for the last
three months about this and one of the
questions that I hear most frequently is
the difference between the two bills is
$3 per year for an insured it's
relatively small amounts of money but
the amounts of money that are property
taxpayers are being asked to pay for is
significant why is it that there's only
a $3 per year extra cost between the two
bills for insured and there's a heavy
heavy hit on property
taxpayers and my understanding of this
is that the nhid only regulates about
half of the insurance in the state of
New Hampshire the other half are states
of Massachusetts Rhode Island
Connecticut all of these other insurance
and when they set a cap um what is going
to happen because all of these huge
insurance companies operate in multiple
States right so if 316 goes through and
they say it's two times Medicare what we
know what we've seen happen time and
again is that you know these gargantuan
insurance companies ABC insurance
companies they're going to say well the
rate for New Hampshire is two times
Medicare we're going to pay that same
rate now for our insured in
Massachusetts and the towns the property
taxpayers are all going to have to flip
the bill for the discount of the
Massachusetts insurance and the New York
State insurers are going to get a huge
discount under Bill 316 and again are
property taxpayers are going to foot the
bill Rhode Island insures huge discount
once again and our property taxpayers
are going to flip the bill and so that's
one of the big challenges with
316 is we are
inadvertently um and unintentionally
providing huge discounts to out of state
insurance and we're asking our local
communities to pay for it through their
property tax payers now I've talked to
the commissioner about it he said that's
outside of his purview and he's
absolutely right it is but I think we
all have to be cognizant of what the
impact of our actions are going to be
Anthem is not going to say well our
Massachusetts insureds are going to
continue to pay more it's just the
discount we're going to give to New
Hampshire policies that's not the way it
happens um and so that's why taxpayers
are property taxpayers that is are going
to get hit so hard um if you try and cap
it at two times Medicare because quite
frankly representative to answer your
question ma'am um 325 is not enough to
keep EMS agencies from going out of
business 325 of Medicare is not enough
to prevent a lot of property tax payment
increases um but it is a compromise and
I will tell you what I like the most
about
725 is that it respects that we have an
electoral process here in New Hampshire
voters show up in the booth and they
elect their Boards of Selectmen and they
elect their city councilors and those
Boards of Selectmen and those City
councilors are stewards of the people
that have elected them and these folks
get to choose what the right rate is for
their Community mind you it's capped at
325 which I find to be hard that say
Stewartstown is going to be treated the
same as Manchester
but it's locally elected representatives
and from what I can see of 316 and I
struggled to wrap my head around this
are we really going to say that
insurance companies and insurance
company executives are better stewards
of the interests of our residents here
in New Hampshire than locally elected
select people and City councilors I feel
like personally having inter right I
trust my Selectmen they're doing it
volunteer and prob Bono why wouldn't
they be given the option of choosing the
right amount for their community and if
they choose the right amount for their
Community why shouldn't insurance
companies have to fund this why do we
have to do everything on the back of
local property taxpayers so that is my
two points thank you very
much uh representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in to testify this morning um
I have two questions uh the first is
that that this bill um provides more
than twice the Medicare rate it provides
for
325 per of the Medicare rate uh so
wouldn't that reduce the impact on
property taxpayers absolutely this is a
significantly better Bill than 316 um
thank you and my second question is um
you said that uh 3
125% uh wasn't enough but we've heard
from representatives of the ambulance
service providers who said that
325 looked to them like a reasonable
amount why are you more uh qualified
than the providers themselves to say
what's a reasonable amount for the
providers great question ma'am um I'm
not better qualified that's just my
personal opinion but what I will say is
the 325 IS I believe the standard that's
used in seven or nine other states in
the United in the United States and it's
325 or higher in in those communities um
personally when I look at this I would
suggest that a place like Stewartstown
um is going to have significantly higher
costs than say a Manchester or a
community that's an hour and a half from
a hospital might have a higher costs
than a community that has a hospital in
it I would love for there to be some
sort of a pressure release valve or
something so that these communities that
are very rural that are very strapped
under their property tax burdens could
maybe pick something higher than 325
followup question further question may
inquire thank you uh but if Manchester
costs less and stewarttown costs more um
but basically all of the um non-contract
ambulance providers are going to get
325 unless they buil for Less um
wouldn't it balance out for the
um it would Statewide but it would still
leave just picking on Stewart Town
example it would still leave stewartown
with a little bit of a hole potentially
that has to be paid by their property
taxpayers so I have a question for you
when we talked about what the insurance
department really regulates is only 20%
uh I think it's going to be more like 30
okay s okay and I think there's at least
another 30 is Arisa plans self-insurance
plans why do you and who are not going
to be affected by this legislation at
all at all why do you think it's fair to
make the small businesses who are in the
fully insured plan to
pay for those larger insurance companies
who choose not to be
regulated because they're not going to
be paying this high fee they get to
negotiate they get to do their own rates
they're exempt from this
legislation so you're saying you think
that's because that 30% of small
businesses in New Hampshire that have
the fully regulated plan they should pay
the $7 mhm to make up for the fact that
that other 30% of people who are fully
insur insured through their employer are
exempt it's a great question Mr chairman
and I apologize the 50% number that I
was talking about is our experience and
my interactions with the the
commissioner so when I've gone through
our data with the commissioner both for
the company that I represent but as well
as the municipalities what we have found
is that the insurance companies that are
under the nhid by an order of magnitude
pay the lowest amount of money in fact
the single largest payer under the
regulations of the state of New
Hampshire pays less than both Medicare
and
Medicaid and so that has been the
challenge the regulated plans and and in
my conversations with the commissioner
it probably inappropriate for me to put
words in his mouth especially when he's
not here U but when I've talked to him
about this and I've showed this you know
I I'll show him that the regulated
insurance company is paying less than
the State Medicaid Program plays and the
unregulated plan is paying seven times
what the insurance company B that's how
it exists
today and I think what we're trying to
do is bring some level of parody um and
that's one of the comments that he's
made publicly was you know we shouldn't
have one insurance company that simply
be because they're the largest
everywhere they get to pay 70% less than
the other insurance companies and all
the insurance companies should be
treated with some sort of equity and
just because you're the biggest doesn't
mean you should get paid the less and in
fact in the 2011 study that was done by
the New Hampshire insurance department
you'll see there was a high degree of
parity amongst all the insurance claims
everybody paid believe it or not even
back then it was between three and three
and a half times Medicare but all
Harvard Pilgrim and Signa and United and
Anthem they all paid the same amount and
what's happened over the last 14 years
is that the largest insurance companies
have paid far far less for ambulance
transports and that's put a bigger
burden on the Harvard pilgrims of the
world and so this plan also brings a
level cuz you're right absolutely right
chairman it's not fair for these
regulated plans to cover so much less of
their cost than the other insurance yes
but I wasn't even talking about just the
regulated so you're only you only
talking about the regulated yeah and
anthem's regulated plans yes okay well
sign as far as I know they don't they
don't have anything that's regulated so
you know right now is only small is only
larger employers arises yes so therefore
they're not even in the game they're not
affected by this
legislation at
all representative spear you thank you
uh you've listed a bunch of numbers
there that don't quite compute to me
compared to other studies that we've
seen can you give us some backup for any
of this that explains something because
we're mixing apples and oranges and it's
not getting clear at all as to where
some of these numbers I mean for
instance it's you made a claim that it's
not fair that
building you know that that Anthem is
paying less and less but that could be
for any number of reasons that they're
paying because they have fewer people in
network could be all kinds of reasons so
I would like to see some backup data but
what you've said absolutely uh
representative um I will tell you the
level of parity uh was from a study and
it's public again 2011 commissioner
cini's office I believe um did it and
that lists out what the insurance
companies are paying for varying levels
uh or for ambulance calls and so you can
see in 2011 what Signa was paying what
Anthem was paying what all of these
companies um I work I don't know
probably 30 communities uh here in New
England so I see it firsthand I'm happy
to share some of this information the
insurance department has not released
publicly a further study um since 2011
that shows what it is but we see
firsthand um and I've brought the
invoices to hearings here before that
will show you these large insurers
Program representative Gibbs thank you
Mr chair if there are some insurance
policies that are Exempted from this
type of Regulation because of Arisa
which is a federal law that occupies the
field for certain types of um insurance
plans is there anything that the state
legislature can do about
that I'm not aware of anything that the
state can do um so the answer is no
correct thank you very much thank you
Rogers representing a hip in opposition
good morning good morning hunt members
of the House Commerce Committee for the
record I'm Paula Rogers and I represent
America's health insurance plans
America's health insurance plans is a
trade Association representing the
interests of insurers and I may have a
battle within my membership because we
have Mr van etton talking about Harvard
doing this and Anthem doing that and
saying things that quite frankly I'm
puzzled about and interested to hear
more about because he may have
statistics and sources that are deeper
than mine but I'm I'm when I signed up I
thought well am I opposed or am I in
support well I'm not I'm somewhere in
the middle and let me tell you why so Mr
vanon and I and Mr stay and I well Mr
staywise and I go back at least to 2008
I think and Mr van a little later than
that and so we th the three of us um
have seen an array of discussion before
this committee and other committees
about what to do about ambulance so the
positive part is that something needs to
be done because we can't keep having
these discussions they become more and
more aggravating and and no solution
sort of emerges so we have 316 and 725
we have two bills coming over from the
Senate and we have the insurance
department study and we have others
saying 325 per of Medicare will take
care of most of the present tension in
the
system I think the charge to this
committee is a significant one because
the expectations are high and so I guess
my sense is that while insurers in
general certainly don't like great
setting um the reality is we sense
something's going to happen this session
on the house side and so I think we all
need to kind of settle down and engage
and you need to listen to us to a degree
but you have a lot of information you've
already gotten you're probably going to
get more and
um I just you know I just quite don't
know what else to say except that um we
want to continue to work with you and we
want to be reasonable and we want to
keep people sort of level in their
expectations and in their statements
because sometimes we hear things that
sort of startle us and so that's all I
have to deliver today but I really look
forward to it and I know this committee
is going to have its hands full so I'd
be happy to try and answer questions
represent miles has a question thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question nothing being
perfect could you get get to the point
where you could
say this is a good
compromise obviously because I represent
an association and different plan
members are within it um I would have to
consult with them I just think it's
clear from the membership I have that
although on the record they will oppose
right setting the reality is they know
they want to be involved in any
discussion because it's important to
everybody uh the people behind me no
matter what side of the issue they rest
upon um something has to be done and I
want to address if you don't mind a bit
of a question you had I think to Justin
van etton about the North country and I
know there's some North Country people
here and on the committee I guess I
haven't really looked at everybody's
biography yet this year but I I didn't
ask that but the reality is um always
over those years there was a sense my
sense that the North country did need
some special ATT attention and I think
you know internal to companies that were
doing the negotiating I think there was
always that representation that long
distances fewer clients that were
insured really do put stress on North
Country operations so I just wanted to
share that reality and understanding of
that particular
situation
followup represent Barz uh thanks for
taking my question I am a North Country
person um I live in I live in the White
Mountains and how much I I we were
talking somebody was talking before
about the um out ofate people and I live
in a in a community where tourism is
huge how is that impacting us well it
depends C where the um billing party is
if they're out of state they do not have
to honor supposing you split the
distance and say oh it's going to be
275% whatever and a bill passes they
don't have to honor that um um the other
problem with out of state carriers is it
puts a burden
on
the ambulance people when they bill and
I noticed that in the bill before you
this morning there's an attempt to sort
of grab on to something about what is a
clean claim because when you're doing
longdistance
negotiations um and you become
frustrated um I can understand wanting a
standard about what a clean clim is and
when it needs to be paid under a
deadline and on that point I'm glad you
brought it up because there are clean
claim Provisions in the insurance code
more on the Pure Health side and not on
the ambulance side and if you're going
to move in that direction you may want
to make sure that you mail them in a way
that makes sense or at least make a
reference to
it thank
you great thank
you
uh so Chris and Cheryl you guys might
morning I thought red was yeah I
know there's no green here it's just red
so you want and you want to make sure
the mic is pretty close good morning my
name's Chris Co I'm the County
Administrator in chesher County and um
wanted to come before you and speak in
favor of Bill
725 um but before I start off I want to
introduce Cheryl Trombley she is our
Director of Finance and sadly our chief
was going to be here today but was
called away
and I I I would be remiss if I didn't
first start off by saying Mr chair want
to recognize you and thank you for your
support and guidance on chesher EMS as
we've evolved over the last few years
it's been important um so a little quick
history and then we're not we're going
to try to get through this really
quickly chesher EMS was a all uh came to
be two years ago um when we our major
vendor um closed it was in business for
60 years it was uh $2
million lean on to the IRS and it was
shut down there's a lot of reasons for
that reason but the bottom line is we
had a decision there's some people in
this room that we look to to see if they
would they would actually come over and
take on the service the last thing we
actually wanted to do was take on this
service but that's the reality that's
where we are today we are um two years
in as I said but really one year as a
real operational um because the first
year we did just uh interf facility
transfers and a few a few
towns um we are
now running five ambulances one
paramedic intercept um um daily seven
seven hours uh seven days 24 hours hours
we've got a staff of
52 uh EMTs amts and paramedics and we
currently um contract with 19 towns on
some level in Chester County out of the
23 we have a a little over a $5 million
budget and we've developed a Continuum
of Care that um has a wheelchair um
Department in it but we actually send
that out to a we we support a private
firm to do that this year alone they're
going to have about 13,000 runs and in
wheelchair Services which means our
ambulances are staying for the 911s in
the interfacility transfers we also do
interfacility transfers about 2,000 runs
this year and we are doing about n
2,911 calls um we are not utilizing
taxes um and we are looking at other
ways uh to do the revenue and we
understand this conversation around um
there's multiple levels that we have to
look at and part of that is private
insurance we also understand because
we've I've had the opportunity to have
lunch with Senator Shaheen and talk
about Medicare and we're going down in
down to Washington in March to talk to
our federal delegation about some of
these concerns other concerns too but
those these are some on our Maps we're
also I've had a conversation with with
the uh the chair about Medicaid in the
state and what we can do we understand
all of these have to work together why
is that
because we're looking around the state
and we're seeing we're seeing struggles
across the board we're seeing Grafton
County have two ambulance agencies right
now that are crisis of not being able to
continue to move forward we're talking
about marac New Hampshire I mean marac
uh County that has an ambulance service
that that actually serves three
communities that's struggling to stay
afloat we've seen exitor and what
happened there I can go on and on and it
all comes down to the reality of of how
do we how do we maintain this how do we
how do we put forward a financial
structure that supports this this
network and we understand in 2026 we've
started to talk to towns that they're
going to have a significant impact of
billing from us and that they're going
to and and they UND and they knew that
they knew they had that three-year ramp
up period and um and that in year in
2026 that they're going to see a
significant uh a significant situation
occur um our product is T is our care is
is excellent we've we've developed a we
have great staff I'm an awe of them
every single day and I at this time what
I want to do is I just want to give you
a little bit uh let Cheryl talk a little
bit about an example of some of the
funding issues that we had you asked for
examples this is one of those and I
apologize I can send this example to you
electronically and get it out to the
committee if if that's something you
would want to do after like that if you
willing to do that that' be great so
Cheryl if you could just walk us through
that okay so um hi good morning every
everyone thank you for allowing us to
speak uh we as he mentioned um have only
been in this business for a couple years
and one thing that's very interesting
being from a County government in
running nursing homes and whatnot um
it's difficult to run um a a business
when you don't know what you're
expecting for income and when we compare
the at least we do know what Medicare
and Medicaid is going to pay but the
insurance companies we don't always know
what's going to pay Blue Cross Blue
Shield in for um example in comparison
to our charges for an ALS or a BLS run
um reimburses about 16% of our gross
charges with Medicare reimbursing
22% uh what we have learned um is that a
very small percentage of our patients
that have the coverage are encouraged
well they're encouraged but a small
percentage will actually reach back out
to the insurance company to Advocate to
pay for the balance Bill and at times
that happens so it to us I mean they
will pay it but it is a a a a game or a
process that they have to play in order
to get it paid but it's a very small
percentage that even know or have the
ability to do this so in turn those
balances um mainly go unpaid we do have
a collection agency that we send them to
and um even though they do go to a
collection agency we really are not
getting any response it's just something
that the balance billing we we we would
like to get away from that having to
balance Bill the patients and if there
was um a more reasonable compensation
and that's why we do support um the
house bill 725 we feel that this is
would be much more manageable for the
the patients that are receiving the care
to then be able to afford the
co-insurance that exists um along with
what the the the contractual or
non-contractual amount that we'd be
spear thank
you so you mentioned that you have
Medicare folks that you deal with so 725
is not going to touch that cuz we have
no no and Medicaid is also something
different so we're not going to touch
that of the folks that are actually on
fully insured
plans that are registered in New
Hampshire how many of them actually have
contracts with the with the um ambulance
providers you know can you you have a
percentage idea speak for ourself I
can't speak for everyone else but I know
we're not we're not actually contracted
with any of the insurance companies
so and it is because if you when you go
to negotiate for the contract prices
they're they're not ad the the the
negotiation is not an adequate
reimbursement so unfortunately we're
left with accepting the amount that
they'll pay now and then in turn the
balance goes to the insured so typically
you don't have contracts okay thank you
representative
wals thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for testifying I was wondering if you
could just clarify something sir um you
had said at the beginning that you your
2911 calls and that you don't utilize
taxes and then later you said you're
going to build
towns so I just needed to understand is
that because when you first started
because you're only did have done this
for two years or contra should be these
are contractually contractual towns that
we have contracts with that's why they
don't have a service we're supplying
that service right I understand that but
you had said you don't utilize taxes but
that when you Bill a town that's it's
coming from the people's taxes right not
using County taxes we're not using
County taxes okay thank you that's what
I
want however as a startup model we are
running a deficit that is a liability
due back to our general fund um so we
are not outright billing through our
taxes and it's not our intention we are
it is go it is our goal to pay back that
liability to the general fund there are
some people on the finance committee who
will ensure that the there will be no
deficit to the county that at the end of
the day whatever de deficit it is
created is going to have to be build by
the towns that are participating and we
believe we have a model so you know we
but we're a startup an emergency
startup really so and and and and the
bottom line the bottom line for us is
what we're finding is that you know
again if if we have a a BLS emergency
base rate of
$1,800 and we have and this is a situ
this is a true situation occurred we
have mileage that adds on another 177
that's a 1,977
that we're billing out right and through
$326 and what was interesting in this is
this is one of those situations where
the individual that went on the got got
the notice that they were on the hook
for
$1650 and they called and they pushed
back and they pushed back and guess what
we got a second Bill a payment a payment
$1,509 and they asked us that the
insurer asked us to pay back the 30 uh
$326 so in reality when it all comes
down to it we're at we're at a Tipping
Point right we're at a crisis and I'm
seeing it all over the place I'm seeing
it in in our own communities where where
towns are you know are trying sh trying
to pay their bills to pay their people
and
this game doesn't help us if they had
just paid the 1600 not not the 1900 that
it cost but the 1600 we wouldn't be here
today we would be in a better situation
and we can show you the the breakdown of
all that representative spear thank
you when you were talking about the
numbers you said uh I I and you'll have
to forgive me if I don't get it right
that you were getting um some percentage
from Medicare and I think you said 23%
22 22% okay 22% and Arisa plans was
another some low that's a breakout of
the of the clientele not not the oh no
no this this was this is actually uh in
response to that that same claim we
would have received a reimbursement of
22% from Medicare but the patient would
have been responsible for their co-
insurance and it the co- Insurance
obviously is more reasonable under that
so you typically get the collection of
the co- insurance when someone is under
Medicare no doubt obviously Medicare
pays a lot less than what this bill
would recommend but um but
what the same claim we're getting 16%
reimbursed by the um the Blue Cross
insurance and the entire balance because
that's what balance billing does it the
co there's no Co insurances anymore the
balance billing basically gives but you
have no contract with the insurance
companies typically and with Medicare
back I don't see how you can survive
this way well that's that's one of the
reasons why we're having the
conversations with our federal
delegation that's why but the problem
I'm having I think and and and this is
the problem I've had since last year on
this is the notion that 20% of the
population is going to pay for the 80% s
that we can't touch and can't do
anything about and I'm having I I can't
get past that particular problem the
fact that in order for you to stay
alive you can't live with 26 23%
reimbursement all the time that's crazy
you're never going to make it so so if
we're going to be if we're going to
be upping the rate for the 20% of people
that are fully insured in New
Hampshire which is only as I said only
about 20% of the
population unless we overcharge unless
we overspend in that small group you it
doesn't seem to add up that you can make
it would you believe which is exactly
why I think fine would you
believe which is exactly why we need to
advocate for the federal government to
pay more so that in turn yes these what
is being presented really we can't wait
till the
Teresa so uh pardon my ignorance on the
billing uh aspect of the ambulance
services but my question is that do we
have uh some agency or regulatory body
or something my question is that is the
services listed under ambul Services it
is same from agency to agency that means
every agency in New Hampshire do they
cost the same amount of money for the
same service do you have anything like
that or or you set to your you can set
your own prices we all set our own
prices and I think everyone has a
different cost for doing business but um
that is some of what was presented um to
this committee or some of the research
is presenting the information to help
quantify our the other bill was all
those numbers were submitted to the
department representative Gibbs thank
you
um does it seem reasonably likely that
if this bill were to pass and so you
would receive for that proportion of um
the insurance plans that are covered by
this bill uh recognizing that a lot of
them that we just can't touch but for
those that are covered by this bill you
would receive three 325 per of the
Medicare rate does that seem reasonably
likely to allow you to operate without
consistently running a
deficit I I think that it's it's our our
belief that it's a piece of the puzzle
to get to that point where we need to be
we the towns need to understand that are
contractually obligated to us that
there's going to be a cost to it you
know we've got to work with our federal
delegation we got to work with the state
you know State reps to to see if we can
do something about the Medicaid levels
in the state all those things need to
all occur and then there's there's other
things that we need to take a look at
but at the end of the day it's
significant
us this this legislation is not about
solving the funding
problem okay at the end of the
day whoever
municipality the ambulance that's in
that is going to get built okay and I
would urge all of you since we're doing
property T you know we're doing your
know Town meetings right now is go look
and see how much your town pays for the
ambulance service and that is a line
item in every every single Town's budget
right thank you very much Mr chairman oh
I'm sorry represent M has a question uh
thank you yes just a real quick question
um if medic care pays you what the 22%
or 177% if somebody has a supplemental
plan doesn't that plan kick in and give
extra money if if that supplemental plan
covers the co- Insurance yes so it
that's where why typic Al payment or
Billings to MediCare at least I think
what we are experiencing you tend to end
up
getting paid for the charge it's one um
because either there is a supplemental
plan or the co- insurance is more
reasonable for the patient to pay thank
you okay great oh R am has a I can't
hold it I'm sorry thank you Mr chair
thank you for for your testimony you
mentioned that there's cases where a a
patient gets their balance bill they get
their bill they submit it to their
insurance company and they end up
getting reimbursed with it I'm just
wondering could you put a notice on the
bill that you send out instructing the
person receiving it that they can do
that so that more people do it so we
actually have a third a sec a third
party billing company we don't do it
right out of our office but when
patients end up calling
because they want to not acknowledge the
bill and again I think sometimes the
bill scares people away so they just
ignore it but those that do call to say
hey wow that's when our billing agency
does um um Advocate that they Advocate
on their own to reach out to the
insurance company to pay the balance and
right now when we we've taken a look at
that it's about a quarter of the those
that are receiving it that are that are
actually trying to take advantage of of
of pushing back and appealing but our
yeah and with our receivables you know
looking at those outstanding
balances the the the the percentage of
the claim that is due from the insurance
is about 35% when it comes to Blue Cross
Blue Shield with the the 64 65% being
the responsibility of the patient and
that's the highest swing
of the um the percentages that are due
from insurance versus due from
patient thank you very
Chris Mr chairman I promise I will be
exceedingly quick so as not to try the
patience of the chair that's why I saved
you for last thank you I you know I
really just wanted to testify because
I'm not anth
um just just a just a couple of quick
points because I want to tell everybody
who you are with that is a salute Point
Chris Kennedy vice president of external
relations for centin and am better
health plans uh some of you may know us
as a Managed Care Organization that
works with the Department of Health and
Human Services to administer State
Medicaid benefits but we also have uh
commercial plans uh uh exclusively on
Exchange and the individual Market with
approximately 25,000 policy holders so
we're not a a big carrier in in the
market and all of our members are
individual uh policy holders it's a very
price sensitive market so the cost
ramifications of 325 per uh escalation
in the rate floor really in the rate uh
could be very consequential to them I
will just also state that about 50% of
our members already receive a federal
subsidy towards their premium so these
are individuals who are are are very
tenuous in terms of being able to afford
their coverage so 325 5% uh of Medicare
would represent an an exponential
increase that could absolutely represent
a barrier to access to coverage uh for
our membership and and frankly not just
ours but the other uh members on the
individual Market including Harvard
Pilgrim and uh Anthem both have plans on
the individual market so yes I think the
325 per is a challenge I also think 325
per without the Stick of requiring the
providers to be in our network is
problematic you're setting a floor for
the negotiating standpoint but you're
not requiring them to be in our Network
and that deprives our members of the
benefits of credentialing and quality
standards that we hold Network providers
too we think that's pretty important but
the last thing I will say and I'm going
to be really quick uh Mr chair is I am
going to make a plug for 316 because I
happen to serve on the New Hampshire
Health Plan board which is the Quasi uh
governmental entity attached to the
insurance department that uh procured
the consultant and and um uh I've been
if you haven't read the report from PCG
I encourage you to do so it's about 45
pages it's riveting stuff but but you
know it's it's actually really
insightful because it is a real-time
market analysis with cost impact of the
kind of rate increases that they they
prop and yes they they propose in that
report a rate increase with some
authority to the department to to
periodically review and even increase
that rate further uh contingent on
real-time market dynamics so you know I
think that that in fact Mr chairman if
I'm if I'm not mistaken that um report
was carried out at the directive
essentially of this commit an amendment
that derived from this committee with
resources allocated from the state I
think it would be a shame to waste all
of that work uh it was a fairly
intensive and exhaustive Report it's
really thorough and thoughtful and
frankly I think it's the way we want to
do public policy uh understand the cost
impacts and market dynamics and then
make our decision right rather than
hoping for the best so with that Mr
chairman I will thank you very much Mr
Kennedy okay as it often happens I say I
have no more cards and then one appears
out of
nowhere and since he is a co-sponsor and
was holding on to his card because he
wanted to answer all the questions and
all the problems you had to know it's
coming but let's not go five minutes
let's go three minutes
because we have another one of your
cohorts
for the record Mark PR Hillsboro 15
Manchester Ward 8 yeah I signed on as a
co-sponsor but didn't turn out the way I
really wanted it to go 325
per. no it will not keep us in in the
black we can't survive on
325 yes we do Bill we bill for HazMat
incidents and I was just in a committee
putting in $1,000 a day fine to the
insurance company when they don't pay
after 90 days shocking the insurance
um so on balance billing recovery I
think it depends a lot on your billing
company uh I actually work uh for eping
fire department we run three ambulances
we have a very good billing company that
recovers uh um money from the insurance
company but also does a good job at
balance
billing um clean claims I mean they look
for any excuse I was talking to another
Ins Insurance company that Healthy
Families rejected like 12 of their
claims for small clerical errors and
wouldn't let them resubmit so on and on
we
go
um you know and I I heard them say well
we hate coming here arguing all the
time well if you stop stealing money
from us when we send you the bill if you
paid it we wouldn't be here but still
you keep stealing money from the
taxpayers and and everybody else because
you don't pay your bills I I I still
have trouble wrapping my head around
that how when you Bill somebody they
don't pay I go to jail if I do
that but they don't um
and Anthem being reasonable in
negotiations and I I just heard the last
gentleman if you're going to raise it to
325 we want to get you they need to be
in network so you can reduce the rate of
the in network rate below the
325 I'm guessing but we need to make it
so these companies can continue you
heard all these other speakers how
they're on the edge right I know uh my
department we're
billing the taxpayers to supplement the
service
because it's we're not bringing enough
in and what are people going to do when
especially the rural ambulances go out
of out of business somebody's going to
have to come in and cover them and
that's going to be a longer response
time longer response times in critical
cases equal death no way around that
so that's what you're looking at and I'm
going to be brief this time and I hope
to see you in the
subcommittee any
questions oh representative miles has
thank you Mr chairman could we at least
agree that this is a step in the right
direction a baby step any step a baby
neonatal thank you very much you're
welcome uh having no more cards I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
725 and I see the sponsors here for our
next bill so I want to move into it
lunch so i' ask all you folks to be as
quiet as possible as you disappear keep
okay representative Pearson I'm opening
up the public
okay good
afternoon it was with great uh apology
that that went longer than I expected I
thought I thought I was doing so well in
terms of the hearing that because it was
unfortunately yeah there aren't there
aren't too many people here right you
got one you got the guy representing
domestic insurance company so you get
one property Cas you got two property
casualties three you got three three G
oh yeah excuse me you got them all now
you got you got them all all right so
for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 which
encompasses the town of dairy now why on
Earth do you have this piece of
legislation before you let me tell you a
story
right
so a constituent of mine
uh traversing down the road broadsided a
car backing out of their
driveway This was
um very clear fault here on this
okay what do you do this person this
constituent of mine never been in a car
do the vehicle gets towed to a sh
the insurance company comes down and
says you know here you go get a rental
car you got to be able to you got to be
able to Traverse the
world and that insurance company the the
insurance company of the offending
party uh looked at the car said we're
going to Total
it that happens all the
time but here's where things went very
wrong very fast
and this is on the shoulders of Liberty
Mutual because they're the ones that did
it
but and I'll also before I explain where
this went wrong I firsthand witnessed
this I was with the constituent their
phone was on speaker for part of this
and I heard this with my own two
ears as soon as they total it the threat
the threatening
started oh you've got to turn that
rental car in right now
right now because we've toldt your car
and oh by the way you've got to sign off
on this total right now because for
every day you wait we're going to charge
you storage fees for that car that we
just
totaled okay wow so there's a little
pressure there into forcing someone into
an
agreement on something they really know
nothing
about but that rental car has got to
come back now because we just totaled
your vehicle so you've got to turn that
in now or you have to pay starting
tomorrow I heard that with my own two
ears shocked at what I was hearing that
a person not at fault in an accident
would be treated in such a manner and
forced to do things under threat of them
now having to pay out a pocket for
something that they didn't
cause
so that is the precipice of this okay
when you own a single car and your car's
just been destroyed
it how do you do that when you're
already freaked out thank God this
person was not
injured you don't know what to do you've
never experienced this before you've got
an insurance carrier threatening you
left and right that you're going to have
to pay for all these things and now
you've got to come up with a way to buy
a car
now so I think there needs to be a
period
here where folks can catch their
breath and figure out what's going on
and how the hell do I get another car if
car that's where this came from
now I'm going to pick on Liberty Mutual
because they're the ones that were on
the on the other line that may not
represent the tactics of other insurance
companies I would hope it doesn't
represent the tactics of any insurance
so that's why I sat down and tried to
figure out what we can do here to
prevent a predatory practice on our
citizens that are at a massive
disadvantage so asking for seven days to
unreasonable the fact that they even
processed this entire claim out to
determine a totaling of a vehicle and
determining that all of the parameters
they did in under a week little
impressive actually that they're on
their game that that
tight
but there has to be some reasonable
thought
here with these with these f folks and I
think asking for them to to provide
seven days of a rental car for someone
to Simply Be able to try to put their
life back
together is is not a tall tail you it's
not a tall ask rather it's not a it's
not a an a significant burden
so that's uh that's the deal with this
that's where it came from and I'm happy
to take any questions you
want okay make sure I understand
was Liberty Mutual the policy holder is
see the the person who was in the
accident they were the policy holder of
the vehicle that caused the accident
okay so this is the other correct not it
was not the insurance company of the so
it had nothing to do with uninsured
because both both parties were both
parties were absolutely insured insured
spear thank
you the policy that I have for my call
car has a line item that says in it in
the event of an accident and the car is
destroyed in any way manner or form
regardless of what
happens I get a rental car and I pay for
that and it's something like $2 a year
or some such Crazy Little Thing like
that
MH we already have I mean that's that's
something that
you choose your insurance company buy I
mean you could say well that guy doesn't
offer it but this guy does so I'll go
with this guy are we legislating because
somebody doesn't understand the
insurance Market or and I and I have an
example that's even more bizarre than
yours my car was eaten by
mice not not bizarre okay it is but that
that's so so let me let me focus on what
you actually asked me the first part so
so
again if you take out a policy and you
don't cover yourself for a rental car
because you screwed up right you you
caused an accident in some manner that's
on you but this spe this piece of
legislation states that when you are not
at
fault you're going to get the coverage
from the other company for seven
days for to no fault of your own here
obviously we're going to get into the
nitty-gritty of the
situation we'll have a subcommittee and
figure this one out yes okay
representative M uh thank you uh just wh
why didn't this person go to their own
insurance company did they have uh car
rental uh Insurance on their own policy
they did
not they had a choice representative
sha uh hold on a second hold on a second
they had a choice but they also had a
choice not to get in to beat an accident
that was not their fault as well no they
didn't they didn't make the mistake they
didn't initiate the ACT here that's
that's the difference with this this
isn't a blanket coverage concept here
this has to do with the per with the at
fault carrier
not not both of
them got it repres sh okay so are you
are you saying that uh if the car is
damaged and goes to the shop then
typically insurance company pays for 15
days or 30 days depending on the policy
uh if the car goes to shop but if the
car total the insurance company do not
pay it is that a standard in insurance
companies so he saying I can't answer to
the to standardization or the specifics
of that but if this car had to have been
repaired instead of just totaled he
would have had a rental car for the
entire duration of the time it took to
have the car repaired I'm aware of that
but are you saying that in in of total
they don't give
it they don't cover it if it's totaled
at all apparently they don't okay thank
you
okay thank you very much thank you Mr
chair thank you for your time chair
calls on Emily Dory from the New
today we like you
better um good afternoon um my name is
Emily dhy I'm the Property and Casualty
attorney at the New Hampshire insurance
um the department has uh reviewed this
bill and um before I go into the details
about the bill I would just as a as an
initial matter I would just like to
address some of the points that were
made about the consumer that um we're
raised I'm sorry can you hear me better
now yeah keep it Clos okay all right um
sorry about that um I just want to
initially address some of the other um
some of the initial points that were
just raised in the testimony that we
just heard I would just um as an initial
matter just encourage um anybody who's
experiencing difficulties like that with
a claim to reach out to the insurance
department we have a consumer division
um we have the ability to process
complaints so if somebody's having
difficulties with a um a claim as was
just mentioned um just described I would
encourage um anyone going through that
to reach out to us to our consumer
affairs uh to our consumer services
division and file a complaint or um an
inquiry um because we will look look at
matters um like such as that
um um where where there seems to be an
issue in the processing of the claim um
getting into this bill um as I
understand this bill um it seeks to add
mandatory rental um coverage in
instances where there's been um an atall
accident um I would
um note that we don't have a lot of
mandatory coverages in auto insurance
currently so this would be
um somewhat different than we currently
have and and on top of that um I would
also mention that currently in our
administrative rules there's a claim
settlement Rule Insurance rule ins
1000 part of the rule that pertains to
to PNC Insurance to Property and
Casualty Insurance is 10002 and within
that rule in 10215 there's a provision
regarding total loss rental coverage
already um the department is currently
reviewing that rule as the rule is set
to expire so we're we're currently
reviewing that rule it'll be go for
public hearing um but the that rule
currently um requires that in instances
where a claimant is making a claim um
for total loss that at least 5 days of
um rental coverage be
provided um to the claimant after an
equitable settlement offer has been made
consistent with the unfair Insurance
trade practice law um so to that extent
um this law uh isn't necessary we are
currently
reviewing that rule as it is up um as it
is um set to expire so we're pro
currently in the process of reviewing
that there'll be hearings on that I
would also mention that in um just
generally even though that isn't
directly the issue here that there's
also a rule in that in that
um in that set of rules
10213 um that pertains to frontal
coverage for claimants where there's
been
um where the cars needs to be repaired
and the um claimant has made a a claim
against the atal party under that um the
party um the claim and is um provided
rental for like kind and quality vehicle
for the duration of the repair um you
know as long as the um the only if the
if there's no delay by the claimant and
the claimant is entitled to repair
during the repair process um so there is
rental um issues already addressed in
the administrative rules um for the
insurance department um and and also
going back to the 10215 total loss rule
that also does address the issue for
insurers who have rental coverage and
says they have to be at least provided
the amount of u coverage they have under
their policy I um we have some just some
general concerns about this bill um you
know the the seven days um May May in
some instances not be enough to settle a
claim sometimes claims take longer so it
could inadvertently provide less Le
rental coverage than is needed um and
then also the bill says that the rental
must be from a regional or national
carrier um we just note that sometimes
um consumers rent vehicles from other
sources such as the repair shop or you
know there's other options now in the
the the out there in the Commerce and
then also some of the phraseology total
coverage just I think that would need
Clarity we're not quite sure what that
would mean um
just as again typically under the law
currently um claimants receive vehicles
of like kind of quality from what they
have and typically for insureds you know
there's there's Provisions also um maybe
a dollar amount that the insured allow
per day under the rental coverage under
their policy so there's just some things
that would need to be looked at for that
um and then typically also if for
insured who have insurance uh coverage
for rental coverage under their policy
and that typically is provided
regardless of fault it's just whether
they have Gage for it or not whether
they purchased it um so and then lastly
I would just say that to the extent that
this is put into a statute that you know
potentially looking to put it in one of
the um statutes that already pertains to
Property and Casualty RSA 412 may be a
better place to put it as opposed into
the these right now this is being
proposed to put into the department of
safety use
rules um and we are happy to work with
um the sponsor and to um look at this
issue further as I as I said we are
currently looking at the um claim
settlement rule that pertains to rental
coverage we're looking at the whole rule
as the rule um is set to expire so we're
in the process of looking at all the
rules in in 10002 and we're happy to uh
work with the sponsor to discuss these
issues not that I know a lot about auto
insurance because I haven't gotten too
many accidents um but my experience many
many years ago I had an accident in
which it was 50 50 you know the you know
who theault
50/50 but other than that if if I have
if we're in an accident and it's clearly
the other guy's fault you know the other
guy pulled out and hit the
car why would I be talking to the other
person's insurance company at all I
should be talking to my insurance
company and my insurance company should
be the one that's negotiating
this this total issue in other words
isn't it my insurance company will
decide whether they agree the total that
it's that should be total or I mean it
and and if I understand the situation
correctly we're looking at the other
parties
Insurance uh appr appraiser
telling someone else insurance that this
is what you're got to do and I'm going
no no my my insurance is with my
insurance company company and it's isn't
it their job to negotiate the the
settlement with this other car with the
car and whe if it's total and isn't it
their obligation to you know to you know
say okay by the way you know you're
you're going to have to provide you I
mean a rental car you or whatever I mean
I I guess if it a cars once it's been
totaled but my mind these decisions are
not made that quickly when it's two
different insurance companies involved
am I misunderstanding the situation
I mean it it it can it the amount of
time it takes to determine whether the
car needs to be total can vary there's a
lot of factors that can come into play
sometimes I mean it you know depends on
the severity of the accident the age of
the vehicle what was damaged and in
terms of the processing of the claim
some people choose if they have you know
choose to go through their own carrier
if they have um property damage coverage
under their policy but some people even
if they have that coverage may choose to
um try to go through the other person's
um insurance company it really is a
personal decision to some extent but
there is you know often as you're
mentioning back and forth uh between the
carriers as the as the as the carriers
investigate who was at fault for the
accident who's who's responsible for the
accident um so there is there is um
sometimes back and forth um I don't know
if that answers your question well
learned more about it representative
speaker
you mentioned before that you know if
somebody runs into a problem with
insurance that they should contact the
insurance department yes have you seen
cases where an insurance
company as their initial tactic will say
no I'm not going to do that I'm not
going to cover you for whatever reason
and then maybe after you guys after you
folks get involved in it they have to do
what they have to do well um have you
seen cases like that I'm sorry um the we
we we have as I mentioned we have the
consumer services um division that
handles um consumer complaints and those
come in for a variety of reasons that um
you know consumers have questions or
they have have a concern about the way
that their claim is processed so it
could be for variety of reasons um but
the insurance department um looks at
those complaints to see whether there's
been um whether the insurance company
has acted in compliance with the
regulatory laws that govern the
insurance companies um so we we look at
it from that it can be there can be a
number of reasons why consur consumers
claims thank you very much I have one
mlin representing All State I guess
opposition morning Mr chairman and
members of the
committee my name is Mike mlof I'm a
lawyer and lobbyist in conquer
representing All State Insurance and
unlike the chairman I do have great
experience in wrecking cars and making
claims I I think what we've seen this
morning is a conflation of uh two issues
one is the ATA party own insurance and
the other's the uh you hit somebody who
is uh uh completely at fault and then
you de to go your Insurance to go to
their insurance so if you have you know
comprehensive Collision liability in
that type of situation many people just
go to their own insurance and suffer the
$500 deductible which they'll get back
on
subreg uh when you look at an automobile
accident you have damages and damages
include loss of property uh physical
injury and loss of use of the car so
when you're looking at that third party
insurance company whether it be mutual
um whatever it's Liberty Mutual
XYZ uh you have a claim for all of your
damages including loss of use of that
vehicle the fact that Liberty Mutual as
the uh ATA party would not pay for you
know the automatic rental for that
person who was hit Is Not Unusual
because there's so many things that have
to be sorted out before they accept
responsibility but if you're uninsured
uh again you still have the same claim
against that third party again the
system is not lightning fast but you're
not going to get an automatic payment
from a third party insurance company um
just because you asked them uh if you
look at the bill there's also I think
some drafting issues
um was not at fault I mean we have a
comparative negligence states so the
determination of at fault is something
that really is not automatic I mean the
police report may put it in but the
accent of ah had they hesitate to try to
make conclusion uh or police or reported
by the decision of an insurance company
I don't know what a reported decision is
I've never seen a insurance company
report the decisions to anybody and most
of them will simply um uh the facts will
stand and you'll either go to court or
not but again the mixing of the two
issues the third party who hits you if
you don't have insurance you do have
your damages claimed and it may take
some time to get it but they're not
going to just uh turn around and give
you benefits until this is all sorted
out but again the um if you don't have
if you have your own insurance policy uh
you your company will collect on that
rental that you have under segregation
uh your damage is included again
property uh physical all those different
things and it this the bill is of you
know a good an idea to solve a problem
that may exist but I don't think this
solves the problem it just conf it
confuses everybody including me and some
of the people on the committee but how
are we going to make a third party
insurance company U immediately react
when the facts of the accident become
quite convoluted but it's a um it's a
mix it's a mix of two sides of the qu of
the question uh if you have insurance
you have great insurance you have a
comprehensive your liability you're
going to be fine if you don't have
insurance at all again you still have
the same claim against that third party
but it's just not going to happen even
under this
bill I think I got it representative
Teresa so um thanks for taking a
question so far what you said is
basically the time taken between
resolving who is at fault not at fault
and the administrative processing time
but would you agree that at the
end the insurance company is going if
it's uh at at fault they are going to
pay for the vehicle if it's totaled or
like the person said he will not paid at
all I mean what is the current policy or
current standard or does it differ by
Insurance to insurance company and the
policies I apologize I I really
well the question okay let me just
simplify it are you besides the fact
that it takes time yeah to process it at
the end of the day when it's processed
would you agree that the insurance
company does pay for the uh Clement in
in in in in the in the event of total
loss of the vehicle in the scenario that
the sponsor presented Liberty Mutual
will end up paying for the damages to
that person now it may take that person
having file a suit but believe me as a
lawy there's plenty of people out there
who take that will damage also include
paying for rental vehicle that is what
was was that rental will be part of your
claimed damages you would claim loss of
use of the car if you got whiplash so
the answer is yes they would get paid
yes but over time yeah okay okay thank
you so now I'm I'm kind of looking at
the sponsor say could this have been
what happened could have been because
the policy holder
the did not not have Car Coverage in
their policy rental car then when they
said to their insurance company because
my I hear the story is is that you know
regardless of whose fault or not fault
they send you the check is quick
is like a jack rabbit they want to send
you the check sometimes it's too too
little right and you don't necessarily
want to your own comprehensive okay and
but but is if you if if the person had
the car rental in their
policy then their insurance company
absolutely would have said fine we'll
take care of this and we'll get our
money back once the case has been
settled but if he didn't have that in
his
policy the insurance company says is um
you're you didn't claim it so we're not
going to cover that we'll have to wait
until the case is settled
and the other party does admit that
they're fully responsible the other
insurance company takes the full
responsibility and says it's a total and
at that point in time he the um um
original policy holder I guess would
then hand the bill for the car rental
to yeah as a matter of fact what happens
many times is an adjuster will come out
and say to you okay we to car it's
$155,000 uh what else do you have to
claim well you broke my antique phase
was in the front seat I rented the car
for two weeks was 1,300 bucks okay we'll
give you 25,000 so that third party
adjuster representing State Liberty
Mutual will come to you and say okay
let's let's s let's finish make a SLE
try to make a settlement then you know
usually it's too low well it's usually
fair but again there is a there is a
process where the the innocent third
party will be approached by the the
carrier who has the 100% ATA driver and
they will attempt to settle the thing as
fast as you know settle the thing uh
quickly right but if the person who is
not at fault does not want to accept
that settlement offer then they get into
the uh details of how do I now recover
which is either um I guess hiring lawyer
uing Mr X who is insured by Mutual of
Omaha whoever it might be to get all
those damages but again it's it's a
contractual issue as representa mcer
said before uh when you look at the
contract you get what the contract calls
for now because you don't have it in
your contract doesn't give you a leap
over to the other side to automatically
get that benefit uh you have to um you
know a lot of people with older cars
only by liability insurance uh the car
is not you know worth the premium to
have it repaired I got a couple I got a
couple old sobs can't get for Subs
anymore but uh so it's a you know the
the the thought that somebody's been
negatively impacted by that particular
scenario of those facts it probably
happens uh more than we want to admit
but again the process is available for
that person to get 100% recovery again
process
okay wait till the subcommittee we'll
figure it okay well go ahead the
hungry now I'm intimidated now I don't
know what to do have you have you seen
cases we talked about what if they don't
have liability insurance and I'm not the
ATA person but there are also
cases where and and I know of these
cases where I don't want my insurance
company involved because I don't want my
rates to go up so I'm going to try to
deal only with the atfa person who is
the other insurance company do you see
those kinds of cases oh sure sure some
people just want to pay out of pocket so
they don't have to make a claim because
that what's that little fox who does all
the um Carfax things you have an the
Carfax information comes from the repair
facilities so yeah if you sitting there
and You've Got U 100% the guy as in the
sario that somebody backs right into you
and you say the last thing I want to do
is contact Liberty Mutual tell them you
got a claim so you say that U insurance
company x what is it going to take to
get this thing settled and again if the
Injustice says uh here's $5 you're going
to no I I I can't do that and you need
that then you need some coverage you'll
go back to your company but initially
some people don't go to their own
company for the very reason of the
history on the car and the um you know
it just it's more convenient or they
feel less uh that they're going to get
hit with a break but 100% if you're 100
100% innocent which is kind of up back
if you're not at fault your rates don't
go
up he
said I've always said that the best
thing you can have is if you get in an
auto accident and the other person said
fault just hope they don't have
insurance because that way you don't
have to deal with their insurance
company at all it's just your own okay
with that thank you very much and I will
close the public hearing this will go to
a
subcommittee uh and we'll
let's try to be back here at
uh well yeah I guess
130 yeah sure yeah so right yeah right
now is
1:15 yeah okay we'll say one yeah they
insurance
e
D to that person now it may take that
suit
e
B
which
e
lunch
momentarily need a clerk clerk you in a
okay we open up the public hearing and
House Bill 507 and here from the prime
sponsor representative Greg I apologize
good afternoon chairman hunt and
committee it's nice to see you all again
um for the record I'm representative
Alicia Greg I represent uh Hills Ro
district 7 which is in NASA I'm pleased
to be before you today to testify in
support of House Bill 507 relative to
the timeline for credentialing of mental
health providers for several years now
we have all heard about the serious
challenges our state faces in
ensuring adequate and timely mental and
Behavioral Health Care Services are
available for our citizens both parties
have taken important steps to address
these challenges but much work remains
before us in September of 2024 a report
from the New Hampshire Behavioral Health
Workforce Center at Dartmouth Health
noted that Workforce shortages in New
Hampshire's Behavioral Health Care
sector have reached alarming levels and
have stayed at those levels for nearly a
decade despite heroic effort from
leaders of all SE from all sectors many
individuals in New Hampshire who are in
clear need of Behavioral Health support
are not getting sufficient help more
recently Roland Lamey executive director
of the New Hampshire Community
Behavioral Health Association noted a
lack of mental health professionals
makes it difficult for patients to
access Mental Health Services there is
no one way to solve this challenge it
will take several approaches one of
these ways that we can do it is with the
house bill 507 which requires Health
carriers to process credentialing
applications by Mental Health Providers
within 30 days of submission to a
complete application this bill helps to
address a bottleneck with onboarding
mental health providers which can take
months at times the current Law requires
Health carriers to credential primary
care physicians within 30 days of
reeding receiving an application and the
bill would extend that requirement to
Mental Health providers with carriers
required to cover health care services
and treatments as in network
retroactively from the date of
credentialing application submission by
the provider in her inaugural address
just a few weeks ago Governor aat noted
as I've traveled across New Hampshire I
have heard firsthand about the urgent
need to improve our Mental Health Care
System there are not enough providers
House Bill 507 will help to address this
challenge by quickening the pace at
which Mental Health Providers are on
boarded in New Hampshire holding Health
carriers to the same standards for
credentialing Mental Health Providers as
they currently are for primary care
physicians as Governor aat uh concluded
when addressing behavioral health during
her inaugural speech seeking care for
your mental health is just as important
as going to the doctor when you're
feeling sick or dealing with a physical
injury we all need to work together on
this and take care of each other I
appreciate your time today I'm happy to
try to answer some questions but I do
know that someone from lifestance health
is here and they'll be able to testify
more to the
particulars so make sure I understand
because I'm reading the bill MH and it
looks like this is already
law right I mean 30 calendar days um it
so what is it about these these little
bullace and moving Specialists from one
place to the other why what makes this
bill necessary what as compar compared
to what's going on in the current law
sure well we already have it for primary
care physicians that's within 30 days
this is adding mental health care
providers currently that is not in
statute that it's within 30 days I see
no reason that we can't also do that see
primary care and mental health providers
yes
I see okay I I just wasn't seeing
it
okay question representative burough
thank you thanks for taking my question
which is I can pull this over um do you
think that when I'm looking at the 30
days do you think that maybe there's a
distinction between you talked about
clean applications between that and I
would categorize them as low medium and
highrisk applicants because beyond the
clinical say here quality and clinical
there's other factors I mean some people
there may be a um a criminal record um
maybe the person uh did residency in
another country do you see situations
where it could take more than 30 days
thank you for your question I appreciate
that I think that there are always
extenuating circumstances however I
don't feel that this is any different
than a primary care provider and if
they've already been able to it's been
proven proven that they can do that
within 30 days with the primary care I
see no why no reason why we can't open
this up to mental health I started
looking at mental health bottlenecks a
couple years ago because we do have so
many it's been very challenging to get
providers so it's where is that Hiccup
and part of it is that it takes so long
in this state currently to get that
licensing and credentialing so I know
that they're very thorough they make
sure about the you know criminal
background and all that but we just have
areas where we've either over legislated
and kind of held the mental health care
into a certain area or in this case um
we're kind of letting it fledgling out
there and not holding it to the same you
know importance that we are primary care
providers for the question Meir would
you believe this is a would you believe
not question
um looking around the country there are
so many cases of credent poor
credentialing that has ended up poorly
for the patient so I would just suggest
there are probably some some for both
Physicians and for for medal healthare
providers where it makes sense to slow
down
thanks would you believe I know you did
twice this was it would you believe okay
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you so much uh chair will call on
it's also Alex and Michelle you guys
going to come up at the same time or are
they going to treat
him come on down we missed you Mr
chairman it had been too long since we
were here this morning we just had to
come back just can't stay away
appreciate it very much DJ beton Court
insurance commissioner Michelle Heaton
the head of our life and health division
so broadly speaking Mr chairman we are
in support of what the sponsor is trying
to achieve in this bill I think she
raised some of the important points with
respect to getting sufficient Workforce
in place to deal with the demand for
mental health services that is currently
in the state my understanding in some of
the private conversations that I've had
with the carriers is that they can live
with including the mental health
professionals in the 30-day window along
with the pcps Primary Care Professionals
to your point representative Burrows
remember that the carrier always has the
ability should there be something in the
credentialing process that Flags to deny
credentialing if there's a criminal
record or there's some other reason that
the carrier feels this individual should
not be credentialed to be in network
with them I'll point out a couple of
different things just that I hope are
helpful for you in terms of background
as it pertains to credentialing so when
credentialing first came into existence
when the legislature first uh
implemented credentialing it was
intended as a quality of service measure
it was a a measure that ensured that
individuals were getting the appropriate
care from professionals who were
qualified and experienced and educated
to be able to render those services that
you were not just having people get
services from Fly by Night
individuals Over time however what we
have seen is the credentialing process
be viewed and in certain circumstances
experienced by providers as something of
a barrier to their ability to to be able
to practice now I think the state over
the past several years has taken a
number of steps to address the workforce
challenges that the state has
particularly as it pertains to
behavioral health as well as other
professions and I'm speaking of things
like the Li your reciprocity reforms
that you've brought forward trying to
eliminate some of those barriers from
people being able to enter the
workforce I think the first half of this
bill achieves a bit of a balance between
preserving the quality of care ensuring
that people are accessing a
well-qualified appropriate provider
while ensuring that it is not an
impediment for that individual to be
able to start taking patients and Bill
and all of the things that are important
for that individual for that
professional the second half of the bill
and I have indicated this to a
representative from lifestance who
approached us about our thoughts on this
bill the second half of it is a bit
problematic and the reason that it is
problematic is
because you know at the end of the day
when we hear from providers about the
pain points that they're
having yes credentialing can sometimes
be a source of irritation and agitation
to be sure but the biggest challenge
they have the biggest frustration they
have is in the Contracting
process and sometimes the credentialing
and the Contracting process are
simultaneous in exactly how that unfolds
is a little bit different carrier to
carrier for example I know that there is
one carrier who will not begin the the
credentialing process until they have
reached an
agreement have a contract in hand with
that provider for them to be in network
once that is in place then they'll begin
the credentialing process and so there's
no friction between the credentialing in
the negotiation piece another carrier
does credentialing in in uh Contracting
simultaneously at the same time and that
I think is where one of the more
obvious hiccups with that second section
arises in the sense that okay the
individuals credentialed in the third 30
days you're giving them this ability to
retroactively
bill but retroactively Bild to what
because they don't have a contract in
place they haven't agreed upon the
rates so that I don't know how that
works for that particular
reason so what I have said to the some
of the supporters of the legislation is
we will engage heavily with the
committee during the subcommittee
process and we will see if there is some
workable language to address that second
piece but in terms of the first section
I think that's fairly straightforward I
don't know that that needs too much work
and again I think you've got some
consensus that the carriers can live
with that and so again if we're able to
speed up that process to get those
professionals into the workforce taking
clients helping people I think we're all
in support of that and again it's the
right balance because you're
not junking the credentialing process
alog together we're just Expediting that
and again if there are issues that come
up the carrier always retains the
ability to deny the credential before I
take your questions I'll look to
Michelle is there anything you got to
clean up no I guess I did all right on
that one thank you Mr chairman happy to
take questions uh we do represent pus
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question I'm
trying to wrap my hand around what you
saying about the company has a has will
have a agreement with the
provider even though they have not
qualified the
provider that in my head says this
insurance company now has a contract
with an unqualified provider which is
not good for the general public would
you
believe I I uh these days I'll believe
darn near or anything but what I would
say is typically how it works and again
Michelle can correct me if I'm mistaken
there will be a provision within that
contract that stipulates that the
individual must be credentialed in order
for the contract to go into effect so
they'll have the contract in terms of
the negotiated rates and the billing
codes and all of that stuff but it will
also say all of this is contingent upon
the individual being successfully
credentialed thank you
representative burrow thank you thank
for taking my question do you think it
would make sense to have just a clause
in there to say that it could go beyond
30 days if they were extenda
circumstances like somebody's and
somebody's records didn't come back from
overseas or just something like that I
think there is flexibility but I'm going
to defer to Michelle on those specifics
so the current statute requires a clean
application and the clean application
um the definition of that is that they
have everything they need to make that
decision so if they needed additional
information that they would request that
information that kind of stops the clock
okay um I think the way the statute is
currently written there is um no way to
get around those time limits and just to
clarify too the 45 days is for
Specialists and currently Mental Health
Providers would fall under that 45 days
so it's not that under the current
statute there are no time limitations
it's just they would fall into the 45
day bucket as opposed to 30 days great
thank you for taking my question um if
you don't have this metric now perhaps
we can have it for the subcommittee but
I'm wondering how big of a problem this
is so do we know out of X number of
mental health providers that have been
credentialed how many take longer than
you know this uh 45 days and um because
I'm wondering if this is a problem or or
if it might be um not really addressing
what the critical aspect is so I would
say that certainly from the perspective
of the providers there's a problem and
so when they come to me and ask me about
what's going on and they're raising
these concerns it obviously becomes a
problem for me but what I would say is
the reason that credentialing is a
problem is different for different
providers some of them don't fully
appreciate the concept of the the clean
application and they didn't appreciate
that they needed a a number of different
other pieces of information to be
included in that so sometimes it's just
a matter of being able to clarify that
situation for them in other cases the
carriers have taken longer than they
should and we obviously address that
with the carriers U but there are a
number of different issues that can come
up uh and it's different as I've said
for every provider but it is a bit of a
problem and as I've said what I don't
want to see is for there to be a ground
sell
frustration with credentialing
potentially being an impediment to
getting folks into the workforce to deal
with the mental health demands of the
state such that we start having
conversations about why we need
credentialing in the first place which
as I've said is an important safety
measure that's in place so what we're
trying to do is bring forward uh I think
what we see here is the opportunity for
there to be a safe and pragmatic
compromise that preserves credentialing
but also ensures that it's not an
impediment to Workforce being able to
come in Michelle are there other
problems with credentialing that should
be highlighted that we hear from that we
hear from providers about we don't
necessarily have data um with respect to
what you asking for because it's not
necessarily clean clut it's not part of
um any of the data submissions that we
routinely get data on um but there are a
lot of misconceptions between the
credentialing datee and the contract ing
date and that's I think um a common
thing that people get hung up on and
they think just because their
credentialing is complete that means
that they should be able to Bill but
they don't necessarily have a contract
and there are no time limits for
Contracting because um at the end of the
day it's up to the parties to come to an
agreement and sometimes those contract
negotiations can take a prolonged period
of
time representative miles thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um for the benefit of the
committee and the viewers at home home
and if I'm directing this question to
the wrong person please correct me um
would you be able to explain um how this
bill would be beneficial to decreasing
the congestion in emergency departments
around the
state boy that's a that's a complicated
question to a very serious challenge the
state
has let me answer it this way as a
matter
of kind of philosophy I guess my belief
is that if we are able to get
individuals into behavioral health
treatment in less acute settings that's
always better you're not having a
situation where the individual can't get
access to a therapist or somebody who
can engage in intensive um Talk therapy
or the other services that these
Behavioral Health Counselors and
providers give um
if if the individual can't access those
Services then their problem is going to
compound it's going to get worse until
you reach the the breaking point in
which the individual then needs to
access the ER and obviously you are all
familiar with the fact that um the
process and it's certainly better than
it was several years ago but the process
of getting people into New Hampshire
hospital is sometimes challenging lack
of beds the fact that before individ
uals would be in New Hampshire hospital
and would have to stay there for longer
periods of time because we hadn't really
stood up a lot of the step down services
for an individual who was leaving New
Hampshire hospital to not just have it
be a situation where they were
discharged from the Hampshire hospital
and the attitude was basically goodbye
good luck you're all set well no that
individual needed that followon care and
again I think the state has done a good
job of investing in those step down
services so that it's not just this
revolving door of an individual being in
the ER into New Hampshire hospital back
home back to the ER in a way in a way
and a way it goes so I think again
anytime you can
bring more capacity to some of those
less acute services to try to deal with
the individual's challenge before it
reaches the point where they need to
access an acute care setting is always a
good thing do we have statistics and
hard data on that I don't but that is my
fundamental
belief very small followup
okay I am under the impression and
please would you believe that um I think
this bill will help in the actual
congestion for patients who are already
sitting in the Ed waiting for an
evaluation and can't get one in a timely
manner meaning not even in 24 hours
they're sitting there waiting for a
qualified mental health evaluator to be
available to come and see them else
they're stuck in that department for who
knows weeks sometimes without a doubt I
think it certainly has the potential to
help I think the biggest barriers in
that process are again it depends on the
nature of why the individual is there if
there's an iea process then you're going
to have to wait obviously for there to
be a Judicial hearing on that and again
fundamentally a lot of the folks who are
in the zers need access to New Hampshire
hospital but to your point if there's
the ability for somebody to be able to
get in there and evaluate that person
and they determine that they don't need
the New Hampshire hospital level of care
well then we can move th that individual
out of the ER and on a pathway toward
whatever less acute uh options are
available to address their particular
m okay thank you Mr
chairman uh Rebecca
s good afternoon Mr chairman and
honorable committee members thank you so
much for giving me the opportunity to
speak today um I am Rebecca starter I'm
a senior operations director for
lifestance health overseeing our
practices in New Hampshire and Maine and
I'm also a licensed independent a
clinical social worker in New Hampshire
um I have practiced in New Hampshire for
about 25 years now in inpatient
outpatient Community Mental Health as
well as uh outpatient private practice
uh LIF stand Health just for some
context is one of the largest behavioral
health providers in the state of New
Hampshire we employ over 210 clinicians
and we have 13 locations uh in 2024 we
treated almost 27,000 New Hampshire
residents uh through 264,000
visits um so we are very committed to
improving access to Behavioral Health in
New Hampshire um I'm here to testify
today in support of House Bill 507
relative the to the timeline of
credentialing we've experienced the high
demand for Behavioral Health Care
Services which have skyrocketed
particularly in The Last 5 Years and the
workforce has had TR trouble keeping up
with the demand um the bill today before
you requires Insurance to process uh
credential applications by Mental Health
Providers within the 30 days from a
clean application uh this is important
at times because historically uh those
credentialing timelines could be 60 90
and upwards of 120 days in the past that
we've experience which is slowing down
the process and a direct barrier to
access
um currently as reflected the law
requires Insurance to credential pcps
within the 30 days this bill would
extend that requirement to Mental Health
Providers with carriers required to
cover cover health care services and
treatments as in network retroactively
from the date of credentialing
application the retroactive billing
provision is very similar to what is
permitted by Medicare through the
credentialing process and sets the
effective billing date as the date of
the clean application being received um
taken together the provisions of Health
Bo Health Bill 507 will address the
challenges posted by greater need for
Behavioral Health Services by quickening
the pace at which Mental Health
Providers are on boarding in New
Hampshire holding Health carriers to the
same standards for credentialing um for
mental health providers as for primary
care physicians and allowing those
providers to build retroactively at the
time of application once credential and
I'm happy to try to answer any questions
you guess they're all said all right
thank you very much thank you chair call
on Peter bragan from Harvard Pilgrim
between you're not oppos not support
he he's a tweener on both bills today I
wasn't wasn't really in supporter
against so I just kind of put in between
so uh uh thank you Mr chairman for the
record uh I'm a middle child by the way
so um for the record uh Peter bragon uh
senior policy adviser with uh Harvard
Pilgrim with uh predy strategies also a
recovering legislator uh and here today
I think for the first time this year
representing Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare
Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare is a not
for-profit insurance company serving
50,000 of our friends and Neighbors in
New Hampshire we operate in four states
Maine New Hampshire Massachusetts and
Rhode Island um and here on uh
specifically Bill 507 uh we I believe
has been stated before like other
carriers uh no particular concern with
the first part of the bill uh the 30-day
limit as we do for the pcps uh that's
something we strive to do anyways um so
it's not really a problem there uh there
is an issue that we would have though
with section two of the bill one that
talks about the retroactivity and it's
kind of been hinted at and and talked
about a little bit that there's really
two pieces in all this there's the
credentialing and there's the
Contracting and they really both need to
go together but also point out that
section two of this bill adds a Roman
numeral 8 to the statute uh it doesn't
show you the rest of the statute but
Roman numeral and I I'm going to say
this because I think Roman numeral 8 as
proposed conflicts with Roman numeral
six Roman numeral six says nothing in
this section shall be construed to
require a health carrier to select a
healthc care professional as a
participating provider solely because
they meet the carrier's credentialing
verification standards so 8 says once
you meet the standards you should be
able to uh retroactively be paid for all
these things and six says no nothing
says just because you're credentialed uh
you're actually part of the network and
everything else so it really needs both
the credentialing and the Contracting
piece to be there although I would say
that it may not be necessary at all
because the contract's going to be
negotiated it's going to say when it
starts and when it ends and what's
covered uh and so really statute any
kind of statutory change is probably not
necessary but as it stands now it
conflicts with six and it doesn't take
into consideration the fact that there a
cont contract has to be negotiated as
well and uh thank you be happy to answer
have well good hey look at
that
perfect chair will call in Paula Rogers
from
bill may not have had my glasses on
anyway good afternoon um chairman hunt
members of the committee I just want to
be very brief brief uh pretty much my
testimony is going to Echo what uh Mr
bragon had to say uh when I picked up
the bill I thought the first section was
reasonable for a couple of reasons um
the pressure on mental health and the
provision of mental health care in the
state but also because we've made a big
deal about integrating Primary Care with
mental health so it seemed to me that if
the primary care provision is a 30-day
provision if you have a credential
mental health worker ready to go to work
you contract with them you should get
that all done as soon as possible so I
didn't think the 30 days was an issue I
agree with Mr bragon that the second
section is problematic one could be
credentialed and if you're an individual
practitioner you could actually start
working the real issue with the payer is
you're not going to get paid unless you
have a
contract and so obviously to everyone's
benefit if we could credential and
contract as quickly as possible that
would make the most sense so I thought
the change in paragraph one was
perfectly fine uh a little work on
paragraph two to straighten that out or
maybe you could State the obvious or
two
good thank
you you got one card left it's being D
that
I will also be very brief but first I
will introduce myself Sabrina Dunlap
senior director of government relations
for Anthem thank you for the opportunity
to speak uh we are opposed to the bill
and share similar concerns that have
already been raised I would just add
that um 30 days I think is more
aggressive than most States I just
wanted to point that out and
um I think you know section two
we would be in favor of striking that Al
together but certainly needs some work
if it does stay in so um that is it I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
speak represent Speer has a
question thank you you mentioned that
it's more aggressive than most States
what do most states have I can get that
for you I just checked with my team
earlier and I didn't get the specific
data but it just was a comment on the
bill when they reviewed it that um it's
a faster turnaround time than most
states have I'm guessing it's probably
45 for most but that's just a guess
follow one further question me inquire
uh if they can if if a doctor a primary
care physician can get credentialed in
30 days do you have any reason why a
mental health care worker couldn't no I
and I don't thank you for the question I
don't think it's an issue and I think we
also strive to um get the process done
faster than 45 days days which is the
current law um my point was just in
terms of State statutes on the issue I
think 30 days is a faster time than most
that represent miles thank you very
brief
question I just want to clarify so the
primary reason your Anthem is opposing
this bill is because it would be on The
Cutting Edge of Time frames for getting
people
credentialed thank you for the question
I don't think that's the primary reason
I was just pointing it out as one of the
reasons followup her original reason to
be posed was section two thank you
you
okay uh is there anybody else who would
like to speak and Senate Bill 507 see
good
okay
e
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill
705 and here from the prime sponsor
representative Emmon good afternoon
repres good afternoon Mr chairman and
the handsome and beautiful Commerce
Committee uh you know you made it to the
big time when a department asked you to
file a bill so yay for me um so this
bill is the request of the insurance
department and I'm just going to go
through a little bit of testimony I'm
not an expert on the bill um it's
basically uh a transparency Bill and uh
some rules around how to make
information
transparent uh it it aims to increase
transparency in healthcare by requiring
Health carriers to disclose specific
cost information regarding covered items
and services under a health benefit plan
it applies to all Health carriers
operating in our state including
insurance companies and thirdparty
administrators these entities will be
required to make publicly available
certain information about the cost of
covered items and services including
negotiated rates within Network
providers out of network allowed amounts
and historical net prices for
prescription drugs the bill will improve
transparency in several ways first it
will provide consumers with access to
accurate and up-to-date information
about the cost of Health Care
Services enabling them to make informed
decisions about their
care second it will allow employers and
individuals to compare prices across
different health care plans and
providers promoting competition and
driving down
costs and finally it will able
researchers and policy makers to analyze
market-wide data and identify Trends and
areas for improvement in our Health Care
system so by increasing transparency in
health care costs HB 705 will help to
reduce surprise medical billing decrease
administrative burdens on providers
potentially and promote a more efficient
and patient centered Health Care system
so I uh request that you consider this
bill and uh
I'm I'm happy to work with you on it
thank you and any questions I I'll do my
best representative buroughs has a
question thanks and thanks for taking my
question representative um on let's see
it's on
page I think it's page two um section
two it says that the is this on
requirements for public disclosure in
this subdivision apply to in network
provider rates so I'm wondering why
that's in there because if we're talking
about insurance carriers or I
misunderstanding it in network provider
rates yeah um I mean it's just another
piece of the information
puzzle so it's line 24 yeah it's a jade
21 Roman numeral 2 on page two
yeah okay so you're talk you're still
talking about the insurance there
Insurance okay got it thank
you so a couple things in the bill that
I found interesting if I could point
that out of course real quick um um
there's a lot of identifiers in there as
a database geek that that makes me happy
that there's a lot of identifiers in
there um on page four line
three it says nothing in this paragraph
requires the disclosure of information
that would violate any applicable health
information Privacy Law and you'll see
that it's kind of there's a aggregation
requirement of 20
uh 20 claims so there's some kind of
aggregation that you can't drill down
into I found that interesting and then
four so it talks about machine readable
files so this there be data files
publicly available on a website that
anybody can access that's the idea uh
the department I believe it's through
rules the department would Define what
those what the structure of those data
files would look like but on page five
line four those files could not prevent
or will will not prevent compliance with
Federal transparency in coverage
requirements so there is a
federal law I think uh president number
45 signed an executive order that
created this and eventually I recently
found out it's been codified into law
but it's the federal transparency and
coverage regulation so there's a federal
uh counterpart to
this and then
finally page five again line
24 nothing in the sub subdivision Alters
or otherwise affects a healthcare's duty
to comply with requirements under other
applicable state or federal laws so it'd
be fully in compliant with uh state and
federal
laws representative peros thanks quick
question representative um where was I
do you know if um what's stated in here
goes beyond what's what the federal what
the federal law lays out in terms of
transparency does it go beyond I think
it's a complement to it I think it my
understanding and maybe somebody coming
behind me will have a better
understanding but that it's a that it's
a complimentary to the federal process
okay that that might just something I'm
curious about thanks representative MCL
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I'm a little
confused here I thought that Health
Services had a whole bunch of a
different um uh charges I mean they're
different depending on who's paying the
bill who the payer is how can you be
transparent when you have a system like
that where it's Peter gets $10 and Paul
gets $15 charged right uh I don't know
that could be in the in the data format
I'm not sure how they would do that
somebody's nodding back there there it
could be part of the data structure that
you know identifies the source I'm still
confused yeah
hopefully Alex will clear it up one one
final thing another final thing my final
final thing final fin the uh the fiscal
note has all zeros which I like to
see and in speaking with the Department
earlier it'll potentially make data
analysis easier so it might make their
job uh less difficult and that that
might be a good thing
so with that thank you well we do have a
question representative sh sh
thanks for a question so as I understand
in the Healthcare System I have seen
three different kind of charges one
charge for the service and then what
second is the charges that insurance
company pays for that service that's
different and then third kind of charge
which somebody pays by cash so there are
three kind of billing amounts for the
same service which charges are you
referring here to publish well I I I
don't I don't think cash would be part
of the data collection so I I would
assume we eliminate that one um it it
talks about negotiated rates so I think
it would be you know whatever that rate
would be insurance company as negotiated
yeah that the insurance company would
pay but again I'm not a super expert on
this so maybe someone will will answer
that behind
me okay I hold up Alex will answer that
question
also all right thank you very much chair
we're calling Alex Fel from the New
department and Jason okay we didn't
in oh okay that sounds
better um the essence of this Bill uh
testimony oh I'll introduce myself one
more time I'm Alex
Fel um what's my title um Health reform
instructor that's since I retired and
came back that's what I'm about retired
um so the essence of this bill is that
it codifies in state law the existing
transparency and coverage Federal
Regulation which requires health
insurance carriers to disclose on a
public
website number one the uh in network
negotiated rates uh that they you know
have contracted for within Network
providers number number two they're out
of network build charges and then the
paid amount on those build charges and
then number three the negotiated rate
and historical net price for
prescription
drugs um so it does
um uh pretty much as representative
Ammon described everything but the U
uninsured cash
consumer this regulation was first
promulgated in
2020 uh in response to an executive
order from then president Trump in his
first Administration and it was aimed at
improving price and quality transparency
in American Health
Care the intent is to make information
available to the public and thereby
Drive Innovation and support inform
price conscious decision making and
promote competition in the healthcare
industry
the regulation requires Health carriers
to make available to the public
including stakeholders such as consumers
researchers employers and third-party
developers three separate uh machine
readable files uh that means files
posted on a website that can be read by
a computer in a mechanized
way um and
uh as you know I just went through the
three types of um price information
there has to be three machine readable
files that are posted so the carriers
are doing this um
today um they are uh posting the
information um but they are doing it um
in different uh formats and different
styles of present
ation um which has in most part had the
effect of making that
information not very useful to
researchers or to uh innovators who for
example might want to create a shopper
Tool uh similar to what the insurance
department has created in its Health
cost website where you can go and put in
the information who your health carrier
is what kind of procedure you're
contemplated and get the price uh for
that that
procedure um none of that has happened
uh which was the intent of the Federal
Regulation uh because of the differing
format uh in in which it's presented and
Jason will give you some more specific
examples of that
problem this bill addresses that problem
simply by taking the Federal
Regulation codifying it
verbatim in state law without adding any
requirements to it with the sole
difference uh which is on page bottom of
page four and the top of page five in
the bill and that provision gives the
insurance commissioner the authority to
um promate a rule setting one standard
format for providing the information so
that all the healthc cares will be
providing it in the same format and then
it will be
usable to researchers to the insurance
department to uh
consumers and um this is something that
this kind of conclusion and plan is
something that came out of some work
that the insurance department did over
the summer under a Federal grant uh
which was intended to help us improve
our health care uh price transparency
efforts and so we were able to hire
manat to come in and advise us and one
of the things we wanted to know is how
can we make use of the new federally
required transparency and coverage
information and their answer to us is
well you can't because it's the the rule
doesn't require enough specificity in
the way that the information is
provided um and they suggested we look
to some other states which are um have
already taken steps to do what this bill
does which is to codify the federal Rule
and then get more specific about the
format in which the data has to be
presented um so we've uh distributed
this proposed legislation to the carrier
um and we have um received just recently
um some feedback that they're concerned
about uh potential cost to them of um
changing the format in which this data
is uh
provided um so I'd like
to ask um Jason at this point to speak
to the these two kind of crucial
developments under the federal rule Ru
that the information why it's not that
useful and why we think uh it wouldn't
proposes thank you Alex for the record
Jason AES director of Health economics
at the insurance department I see almost
everybody here knows Alex's name and
despite that he struggled telling you
what his title is for the record I call
him FDC former Deputy Commissioner of
the insurance department so henceforth
you shall be known as such um thank you
for your time and hearing this important
bill I just wanted to Echo
representative amon's closing statement
about efficiencies in economies because
I think we're we're I'm always very
sensitive to not incur additional or
superimposed costs to our private
businesses that perform important
services to our citizenry and I too
believe like he does that this might
make the process of transparency in
complying with Federal rules actually
more efficient and that's really that
weighed heavily on us in in the
synthesis of this bill um that we worked
hard on so I think I don't want anybody
to lose sight of that that's important
um with regards to the mechanics of it
there are three machine readable files
that we've specified in the formatting
requirement the federal rule does the
same although we see very spurious
compliance across the Continuum of of of
carriers submitting data it's it's not
to say that they're non-compliant it's
that they Cho choose different
formatting Styles and as a result it's
quite chaotic heterogeneous and and
really of low utility to the users like
State regulators and even consumers it's
it's noteworthy too that the federal
rule requires that insurers post on
their website a consumer friendly um
file for which consumers can um or or or
application for which consumers can go
and get price estimates on their own
these machine readable files don't
coincide with that intent rather they're
more for analysts people who have the
the resources both um physical and
intellectual resources to be able to
handle large data sets and complex
health care cost data and the latter is
what this bill aims to um improve upon
and the three machine readable files are
systematically organized like that for
the reasons that um the representative
to my left brought up and in
representative melair about this
variation in prices so notably you you
you'll see in network negotiated rates
for those providers who are in contract
with carriers they'll have a specified
rate and it's listed by procedure code
that's our vernacular for how much did
it cost for the procedure that I had
that's an important regulatory tool for
us in the insurance department the
second file is out of network allowed
amounts which not all providers in our
healthc care system are in network with
insurers so for that purpose there's
Merit in understanding how much those
Services um are charged for by out of
network providers and what the paid
amounts are and then the third file is
essentially a prescription drug file and
I don't have to tell anybody on this
committee the importance of prescription
drug price transparency and it uses a
slightly different by really interesting
and effective methodology to get
reference data for that information so
we believe that this is really um a
sensitive approach to improving our
important price transparency efforts and
it's a big part of the work that we do
and um I thank you for hearing that
long- winded story and I welcome any
spear excuse me yeah I didn't have my
hand up but
I'm sorry we're we we're easily
confused thanks for taking my question I
just need clarification of something um
on page two section two do all all do
all the in network provider are all the
uniform no no that's the that's really
that's a great question and that's one
of the best utilities of it to see price
variation across a contain Continuum of
providers and there there is indeed much
you know many of you may know of our New
Hampshire Health cost website we do much
to try to stabilize that price variation
by provider and and by carrier that we
communicate to the citizenry into
purchases and anybody else interested
and it is indeed quite a task so price
variability is one of the main
overarching issues for these you know
robust
this representative
sharesa uh
so so uh my question is that uh if I
have certain insurance I do get the
price that the insurance going to pay
for that service so does this bill
basically work on getting those prices
available to all the public not the
person who is having that insurance is
is my understanding correct both I mean
the the consumer friendly file is
intended and by by federal law the CER
is required to give you precise cost
estimates for a procedure at any given
provider that they're in network for and
I'll let Alex say say more on that yeah
the intent is both to um give the
covered person access to to information
about the price that's been negotiated
for the service that that person is
contemplating having and also for
example large employers might be
interested in comparing the negotiated
rates from one carrier to another to
determine what would be the cost of
Contracting with this carrier versus
this carrier for the same coverage
because it'll vary just to follow up F
the question mequ
so uh so I just want to clarify myself
that so the information that you're
talking about cost of procedure paid by
the insurance that's already available
to me being a you know having that if I
have that insurance what is this going
to do ex additional is it is it saying
that that number should be available to
everybody even if that person doesn't
have that insurance well the actual
price of that information is not today
easily available to you even as a
covered
person it is further question question
no that before the procedure when I do
get that in the statement that this is
how much the insurance going to cover
the cost the cost this is the cost from
the insurance that is going to cover for
that procedure I do get that in in the
statement yeah we're um getting
uh crossed here crossed up on the
distinction between the cost sharing
that you can get access to that
information how much it'll cost you the
consumer versus the actual price that
gets paid for that
service followup further question no I
do get the both I I get how much the
insurance is going to pay for their
service and how much my portion would be
I get both the information for that
procedure from the insurance that I have
is this bill going to so my question was
that that information is already coming
to me from the insurance that I have but
is it does this bill say that I should
have the information from the all the
other insurance company also for for
that procedure that I don't have yeah
you could compare like um I know I'm
going to have this procedure and I'd
like to know what it would cost um
through this coverage versus this other
coverage and you could find that
information thank you
okay re thank thank you for letting me
ask a question thank you for U
presenting the bill
so is it fair to say that this bill is
really a specification to the IT
department to say you have all this data
and here is how it needs to be presented
in these files so that you so that we
can have ai look at it and solve all of
our are you know questions so is it
really the specification part of how to
present the data that you already have
in a common format and then let AI take
over thank you for your thoughtful
question I would probably say let ja and
MPH take over those are my initials and
Morgan harrises not for AI because I
like many of your colleagues here
concerned about the ambiguity of that
and the uncontrollability and
untenability ability of that we we as
Regulators often get calls at the
insurance department through our
consumer services division about
patients getting Expo facto after
they've had the service um they were
unaware of the price that they might pay
so we do much to try to give our
citizens our priority information over
what the price is and it turns out to
representative maier's comments I mean
that's very spous and cryptic actually
so the purpose of us specifying this a
naal more
standard homogeneous format across the
Continuum of carriers that we regulate
is so that we can do a better job in
reporting that outward and then also
reconciling disparities when we do
indeed get consumer complaints which is
often on why they paid this amount when
they thought it was going to be another
amount and often times it's it's a an
opportunity for Education rather than
non-compliance on the insurance part
it's th this can be very challenging at
the consumer level to find out what
procedure code actually applied to the
service someone had not you know um
there can be a blood draw for lipids and
there's about 40 different procedure
codes just for that something so simple
from a billing in in in reimbursement
standpoint is actually very complex and
and we you know we I often times
struggle considering the Merit of the
federal rule requiring that insurers put
the consumer friendly format there
because it's somewhat of a
misnomer because the number one mistake
consumers make is not having the right
procedure code and or being able to
figure out among the the the host of
procedure codes listed when you type in
lipid profile which one did I have and
it's not fair to providers who do great
work hospitals who provide a lot of
services and carriers is who finance it
for all of that Enigma to exist and so
to that end we take our responsibility
to communicate these rates in an
interpretable way very seriously so
that's a very thoughtful question I just
wanted to you know respond in that
tongue and cheek fashion about AI but
also make it clear that you have two
data analysts working extensively to
ensure the Fidelity of the outward
facing nature of these important
Healthcare
uh who should we start with first today
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record again Peter
bragon representing Harvard Pilgrim
Healthcare the state's not for-profit
health insurance company and uh yes once
again I didn't put support or oppose I
just put that we do have some concerns
and we do um the intent here is great in
fact uh something we support
transparency uh there is a federal
program that exists we already do this
um and so um the concern we have and I I
guess I have to correct the
FD uh C the former Deputy Commissioner
uh who said the the department just
recently received followup from the
carriers um in SE end of September the
carriers were sent a draft of this and
October 10th the carriers responded
saying we're concerned we got some
problems and then we never heard back
from the insurance department so we have
some major concerns uh and to say it
just recently came up I think is a is a
an understate stat uh we do support the
concept of transparency uh we are
already doing this uh as was noted
there's a federal law that requires
these big data files to be submitted and
by the way this is not something for
consumers uh each of these files that is
submitted and there's not three uh each
of these files that's submitted is I
believe uh three and a half gigabytes in
size so uh Joe consumer uh at his laptop
with his notepad app um I can't even
read these files it's just too big for
anything that I have um and the carriers
including har Pilgrim has spent a lot of
time effort money and resources putting
these files together and one of the
problems we have is the overall testing
of it and everything else because the
files are so big you just can't pull it
up in anything normal um but the scale
of let me say there are three three file
types that have to be done one for in
network one for out of network and one
for prescription drug okay that's fine
that sounds like three uh that has to be
done for every single plan so in New
Hampshire uh I looked at the Harvard's
uh transparency site where these files
are uh for New Hampshire I counted at
least 24 of these plans that we have in
New Hampshire for all the different
things that we do um and then for each
of these files uh it consists of uh for
each of the 24 plans then there has to
be a record for each billing code for
every procedure of which there are
thousands uh and then the rates we
charge for those procedures for that um
provider of which there are hundreds so
you have basically a data set that is
thousands of Records times hundreds of
records for providers uh times only 24
plans for us I can't imagine how many
some of the other carriers have uh and
you end up with gigantic files so
basically we have 24 files Each of which
are about 3 and a half gigabytes in size
Each of which has to be recreated every
month uh the one for the Auto Network
rates if I understand it correctly has
to include the prices every price paid
for a procedure within the last I think
60 or 90 days to every single
provider these are gigantic it took us a
long time and a lot of effort to create
them and our concern is and the
testimony you heard is correct for the
most part what's specified here mimics
what the federal transparency law
requires in terms of what's supposed to
be in there uh however the thing that
concerns us the most is the piece at the
end uh I think it's at the end that
basically allows the commissioner to say
okay this is what the format's going to
be uh this is not something you can just
flip on its side now if the uh
department wants to make something that
goes in and looks at these files and
takes out the data that it wants okay
fine and I I understand from the
testimony that uh the federal data
specifications were not that exacting
and so people are doing different things
uh so maybe there's something we can
work on there but I guess uh to
summarize it we're very concerned the
scope and the scale of this is gigantic
we're a small Regional not for-profit
health insurance company uh a lot of
time effort and expense has gone into
making this to comply with the federal
laws um and rather than changing the
spec so we have to have a different
format for New Hampshire uh you know
Maine's going to want a different format
mass is going to want a different format
rhod Island's going to want a different
format uh and again every 30 days we
have to generate these things so uh this
is not something simple and uh there's
got to be a better way I think that
would probably wrap up my comments and
happy to answer any questions you might
have thank you very much anybody have
any
question thank you okay next up uh Paulo
Rogers from AIP who's in opposition to
the
bill obviously chairman members of the
OB first born I'm on oh excuse
me I'm representing ahip with America's
health insurance plans which is a trade
Association and I've heard one of my
member companies give forth with great
strength I have confusion because I sort
of come to this late um I did not get
notice back in October that something
was a fly and I sort of took on this
present task on January 1st so I had to
do some homework and what I understood
or understand or think I understand is
that what is going on is the
Department's well aware as many of the
plans are of their obligations at the
federal level for both plans and
hospitals as well to file immense
amounts of data I think it's under the
high-tech Act and the outcome of that
has been somewhat anemic a lot of
confusion I guess the hospitals filings
are sort of less comprehensible than the
pl filings but they're not easy files to
work with uh when I first saw the bill I
thought well I guess what trying to do
is have the local plans that filed
federally just import that information
and give it to the insurance
department which would be pretty
Monumental in and of itself but what I
understand and this is the missing piece
for me and I think we could have more
discussion with the Department to
understand it is that the intention is
to look at the federal format and say
well for State purposes we need to alter
that format in some capacity so we don't
yet know what that would be it would
come through rul making so I think
that's a discussion that needs to be had
and plans are ready to have that
discussion with the department and so
for the moment I'm signed up some I sort
of in between I'm more leaning toward
direct opposition because this time at
this card so anyway so there it is and I
feel sort of totally unequipped to
answer any technical questions but there
is a lot of puzzlement I understand data
is important and it's certainly
important for policy makers like you we
have hopes that consumers will use
complex data and learn and model their
ways to save money and go to the right
people the reality is the consumer
uptake on this kind of information is
yet to be compelling to them so we have
a lot of work to do so anyway I'm
willing to along with my plans have
further discussions and as I said I'd be
happy to answer any questions but I
to representative mcair uh thank you
thank you for taking my question I I
guess I don't understand why the states
can't do this information in the same
format that the federal government
wouldn't that make it easier for
everybody well the information is
available to anybody federally any one
of you could go and access it if you
wanted to so and the insurance
department can do that some states have
made sort of efforts as New Hampshire
insurance department is doing in good
faith to see how that data up there
might have meaning for their
constituency and so the plans are the
reporting people and they need to
understand exactly what that is all
about because the department would
assure us that there is utility to that
data and we need to understand the
format and so it's it makes us very
uncomfortable and that's why we're
opposing the bill in its present form
okay
Alex do you mind coming
you I have let me ask my question and
then you can ask
yours I assume you all
be okay so The $64,000 Question
is what's what is being reported to the
Feds that is not is not helpful or
useful or what what are you looking for
that you're not getting that's from the
feds and wouldn't it just be easier that
whatever they submit to the feds they
submit a copy to you and called us a day
well the the main problem is what gets
posted and publicly available is not in
um any uniform format so that be let me
rephrase my question what is the wrong
with whatever
they are sending to the
feds which is different from what the
federal government is posting right
because Federal government's putting it
through its word procer it's cruncher
and doing some other funky things with
it so whatever they're
sending they're sending the same
information to you yeah and then you can
take and do whatever you want with it
that's the underlying intent is to
result right where you finish but the
Federal government stopped short of
exactly specifying the format for
carriers to submit them so they gave two
options submit them in Json forms which
are internet style JavaScript not
notation or HTML files and in those
cases carriers are are to put um a
directory essentially a map on how it's
nested a as a result of not being very
exact or clear on the specification form
that across the carriers in our state
that we regulate you like you heard
Peter and they they were very compliant
but the way that they submitted was for
each plan a separate file for each plan
whereas other carriers have all of the
plans that they
offer in one file in in a very very
complex
Network and a third carrier has a the
file organize in a way that there's
hundreds of columns that are really
unnecessary and none of them are
nefarious and of themselves it's just a
non-standard format and taken together
it renders the files not very useful so
when we worked on this our imagination
was to take the reported variables that
as um representative Ammon said are well
specified on each line in in the statute
and require them to just submit a CSV
file it's a it's
a a glorified type of Excel file that
has just that information with regards
to the breadth of the content and
information for prices I'll just um in
the interest of not challenging Mr Bron
I would just point out to everybody who
goes to a supermarket that the average
supermarket has about 160 to 180,000
products that are individually priced
and they seem to do a decent enough job
keeping track of them and we as a
society seem to think it's pretty
important to know what the price of milk
eggs butter bread and cigarettes if you
buy them and I hope you don't but the
the point being we we we have a price
awareness of those things it's very
complex but there are lots of examples
of how that's communicated to the
consumer why shouldn't Healthcare be
like this this is an attempt to make
that
better so um Mr chairman um there was
something you said that uh gave me the
impression that uh you're assuming this
information gets filed with the federal
government and it it doesn't the rule
the Federal Regulation just tells each
carrier to post this information on a
website which is absolutely useless if
every carrier is doing something
different different right now
um now there we can't make this up we
are
um in going to be in
conversation okay with the carriers how
about how about we have a statute that
says that you will work with the
carriers in New Hampshire so that we
have a uniform system in New Hampshire
without predetermining it at this point
that we want you to try to work to come
together to have a
uniform methodology yeah something like
what Paula suggested that how she first
understood the bill it's an interesting
idea that we're going to follow up
on
spe realizing
that realizing that the carriers are
having a bit of an issue and realizing
we have to get a certain place and
realizing that their outputs are fixed
in
format and we'll eventually have an
output you know the state will
eventually have a format that they want
that's a problem in an
algorithm it's not a problem of I have
to reformat every piece of information
that I have here it is an algorithm that
can turn that thing into the format that
we need so the question I ask is if we
go along with the kind of thing that the
chairman was talking about we could
conceivably simplify this a little bit
by them providing an algorithm to get us
where we wanted to go once you have that
decision as to an exact format we don't
have to convert everything that they
have it can be an algorithmic result and
an an algorithmic solution as oppos
there if there's stuff combined I'm
sorry if there's some things combined
doesn't matter when if as long as it's
fixed in format an algorithm can change
it yeah but the algorithm won't know
what percentage of difference in between
every every every provider would have to
provide their algorithm but it's better
than converting all the data might be a
less it might be less
impactful than trying to convert all
that data every single time right it's
essentially I'm going to call Paulo's
idea um which is that each plan will
import the information and report it to
the insurance department using you know
a crosswalk or an algorithm um I don't
know to give us the information we need
well if the federal government is
saying that just you can do any one of
these multiple different formats okay it
and then in New Hampshire we only have a
handful of
companies it seemed to me that now I can
I can imagine we have some differentials
because you know we have some big
players and we have some little players
so and I can only imagine that the way
the feds did that is because some
lobbyists were in the room that say well
we can't do it that way or we need you
to to do it our way and so then you got
every every Lobby everyone wants to do
it their own unique way and knowing full
well that the information is now going
to be useless to the consumer because
they really can't compare and uh um not
that I'm cynical about the legislative
process but I sometimes I can see it
happening right in front of me so I
guess it would be yes it would be in a
perfect world that we could get you to
do take the companies that are in New
Hampshire
and to all have them agree to do it the
MH so we don't have that many companies
and right I mean I don't see Signa here
right now but there he
is it's easier to make our state a
perfect world it's easier just to say
you know we we would like to see if
they're willing to work now I mean anite
say no this is coming down from Indiana
and you know we're going to do it our
way then maybe we have to do it their
way
but they're so big and
nasty but but it's something it would be
nice if they could all if they could
come together and say okay let's have
one one uniform way and in the long run
that would be actually useful to New
Hampshire
constituents so we're going to be
working on working with the carriers to
see what we can come up with perfect
don't oh there you go all right you
really wanted Chris to come up
first okay all
right right okay
can both come up come on up you know and
thinger okay well you know you know in
Washington they always have panels they
always have multiple people they you
know they kind of along you know and
then you know and they have corporations
you'll see four different corporations
and you think How can any of these these
four have this have anything they can
agree on but I've never gotten to
testify next to another carrier what a
delight right I'm I'm
Overjoyed I'm Spina Dunlap senior
director of government relations for
Anthem Chris Kennedy vice president
external relations for centin and Better
Health Plans um so I have just a couple
of things that have not been said that I
just want to flag um so initially when
we saw this bill we thought it just
tracked what the federal government
already requires but then um I sent it
to our team that handles transparency
and they were like the concern is around
the format of reporting the data which I
had initially missed which is that line
that was pointed out that is the key
difference um and Anthem has seen this
play out in Colorado where it was
something similar where uh their
insurance commissioner said we will you
know promulgate rules at another time
and again I think that bill also largely
tracked what was already required under
federal law and as it turns out it has
turned into um a situation that is quite
difficult to navigate because the state
requirements are quite different it's
turning out to be a different process
different formatting the knowledge of
how these files are submitted goes
beyond my comprehension but I do know
that it is very complicated it is a ton
of data I know they're involving RT IT
architects um to make those changes at
the state level so I just wanted to
point out that when we talk about these
things there is a significant cost to
them so I think it is very important to
talk about what is the purpose what is
the use and we do already turn over a
tremendous amount of data both to the
federal government and with the state I
mean all of our rate filing requirements
other data requirements things around
rebates and Drug pricing we turn over a
lot of data already so I just wanted to
point out that there is a significant
cost every time we're required to do
something in a different format um so I
just wanted to caution you on that and
one other sort of technical thing um
there's a line around requiring
prescription drug files that's not
currently finalized under federal law
and so um our team just pointed out it'
be helpful to pause that piece in
particular um because we actually
haven't gotten the rules from the
federal government so um that would be
super helpful but I will now turn it
over to Chris yeah and and I appreciate
not not to be uh redundant I mean I came
in this afternoon I actually had no
objection to the uh the bill as
submitted until I started hearing about
it um I you know I will I so I will just
say and again you know the the the scope
and range of the data the Herculean
effort it takes fine you know legit
originally look at and I say some poor
data analyst team uh that has nothing to
do with me is going to have to do that
poor them but the only thing I will I
will just offer up is in looking at a
lot of the definitions under uh page two
and
three and I have to say this makes me
question that the federal requirement to
begin with although that's not my
jurisdiction and I don't know what the
Catalyst for that was most of this
information it strikes me would be
completely useless to Consumers
completely useless now I don't know
again what format that the department
department is going to going to present
it and or aggregate it um obviously we'd
love to have dialogue there and let me
just say the department does a
tremendous job uh uh with respect to the
data collection and price transparency
and a tremendous job in working with the
carriers towards that objective which we
all want to achieve um but I I I just
think some some further dialogue would
be useful just in terms of making sure
that we're presenting something that's
actually consumable and useful for
consumers it strikes me that a lot of
these things I don't know how many me
everyone on on the panel has health
insurance how many of you care what we
pay one provider versus another it's not
reflective of what ultimately your
charge and what your premiums are what
your co-pays are it's a lot of the
information is nebulous and irrelevant I
sponsored the original build that had
the insurance department and the goal
was when we had Tyler doing this was
that you would have different bills you
get the doctor's bill for a surgery you
had the doctor's bill you had the
hospital bill and then they had the
anesthesiologist Bill okay and they were
all separate and so how could you
compare a procedure you know like I'm
going to do a proced
colonoscopy how do I compare that from
One hospital another if everyone had
they didn't all have what the cost price
is for the service yeah absolutely but
what what what what our fee schedule is
with the provider I mean I think is is
less useful data so anyway it's it's all
towards uh uh I certainly would would
look forward to having further
conversation with the Department on how
we could make this consumable because I
do think by the way I think we also do
this a lot in our in our member it's
already available on our on our websites
and our member handbook and what we
think is a fairly consumable format for
our members um so anyway I I'll one more
I I was remiss and um I did not mention
the fact that we have talked obviously
with the insurance department and
appreciate their collaboration on this
and will continue to have conversations
but um anyway I wanted to get those
concerns on the record great and you all
language represent wsh has a
question yes does the um excuse me the
uh New Hampshire insurance department
have the power to tell the insurance in
New Hampshire the carriers that they
want it in a they want data in a certain
format only if we give it to them so it
has to be in a has to be a bill we have
to legislatively you're asking them so
no I ask as a chairman of the committee
I often ask departments to fix it
without legislation exactly okay uh and
yes so in this case we might end up um
retaining this
bill saying that come September we would
have want to know that they've resolved
it yeah
followup further question be inquired
thank you so just from what I've been
hearing the the push back from the
insurance industry talking about oh
these files are so big and oh my gosh
how are we going to do it and I coming
from the computer industry um I find
that hilarious actually but because
there is something new out called
software Engineers who make a living of
doing being able to do this kind of
stuff um but it also repeats why this
bill is needed because you know if it's
that dark and deep and complex for you
guys what is it to the average consumer
and how are we going to kind of figure
this all out and that's why the
insurance department came in and said
hey this is deep dark and complex and
from all of these different carriers
they don't do it in the same way let's
try to have one format so I absolutely
agree with this whole concept of making
it that way so that's a would you
believe I'm sorry yes it
is okay Mr chairman can I just say and
I'm not diminishing at all the the
effort it takes to to replicate these
files but and so but I'm I'm sensitive
to your to your to your concern your
your example there but uh I will just
say you know what my interest chiefly is
is is let's let's make sure the DAT is
useful I'd love to work with the
Department to make sure we're
disseminating this information in in a
way that's actually useful to Consumers
I think we've we've almost learned more
about the federal provision just just
now and the uselessness of it and let's
not replicate that so I'd love the
opportunity to further have that
dialogue with the
regulator great thank you both very
much having no more cards done they will
so um I'm working on my uh for next
week and uh since insurance people are
in the
room um we will uh Wednesday we will be
insurance tues and then
Tuesday uh in the morning we're going to
do the liquor we'll do cannabis and
liquor positions Tuesday morning at
10:00 a.m. thanks and then in the
afternoon um we'll take up three
business
subcommittees and then Thursday's
session is that Tuesday and Wednesday
next week it's Tuesday and Wednesday so
Tuesday will be downstairs in room 104
that is small and Wednesday I can give
you all a peak of my old office down